My road and that road may or may not lead you in a good direction,
but you're going to stay on that fucking road.
If you're attached to an ideology and it could be a terrible road,
it could be a road of,
you know,
circumcise your daughter's clearest because that's a fucking tradition.
I mean these fucking crazy pitches in Africa than cut holes in their lip and
stretch them out to put plates on.
Why is that?
Because they got on a fucking road and they stick.
They stuck with that road regardless of rational thinking.
They didn't use rational thinking at all.
They're just adapted a predetermined pattern or behavior that makes life so much
more simple and that's what every fucking religion is.
The problem is no one knows you cannot.
No.
You can have your own beautiful personal experiences.
You could have been the person that was actually touched by God,
but when you start yelling and random whatever,
who left the following behind,
you got two things going on at the same time,
Christian is going to be taken away first.
I know you're full of shit.
And you know your full chef and the real problem is you can't say it because
everybody's got this freedom of religion,
freedom of religion,
religious freedom,
the freedom to express yourself.
Even if you're expressing yourself with nonsense,
nonsense that helps.
Scared,
lonely,
sad.
People lock onto that nonsense so they feel like they're a part of something.
I mean,
that's what it is.
That preys on people whose lives fucking stock.
So it's all nuts.
It's not like your shit's cool at,
it's not,
and it's not big.
You know,
Yoga is the answer or fucking mushrooms are the answer.
There's,
there's just questions and until we're honest about that,
we're never going to evolve as human race is stuck in a giant quagmire when it
comes to our behavior and our thinking about our behavior.
But there comes a certain point in time where you have to pop train out and you
have to recognize that all this morality that you've developed is good because
it's good to treat other people good.
It's good to treat other people the way you'd like to be treated yourself.
That's like a fucking golden rule.
And there's a reason for it.
And that reason is that we're connected in some strange way that we don't
totally understand.
Unless you are good to other people around you,
unless you are kind of friendly and warm and loving,
you're not going to fucking enjoy this life.
You're just not.
You're going to be problems everywhere you go,
you're going to have problems everywhere you go.
You got to figure out a way to enjoy this fine line of it's not because of Jesus
is not because of Moses.
It's not because of anybody that may or may not have ever existed is because
that's how you fit in better in the world.
That's how you stay positive.
And it doesn't have to be some shit that was written 5,000 years ago on fucking
animal skins.
That doesn't have to be the golden rule because it's old.
You know?
That's dumb.
We need to figure out like now,
today what?
What is,
you know,
the best way to live your life?
What is the,
you know,
there,
there's gotta be ways that you can be putting forward the most positive energy.
I mean,
we know objective Lee,
what's causing pollution.
We know objectives,
what's causing birth defects and you know,
and we're taking it too much chemicals and not enough vitamins.
We know objective,
we all this stuff.
We know how to organize our world and yet we don't do it.
We know how to organize our health and yet very few people do it.
We know all these things.
The right path to like being like the happy healthy person is to do all the shit
that we already know you're supposed to do.
Take care of your body,
take care of your health,
take care of your mind,
your stress,
meditate.
Be kind people.
We all know that.
We need to ask anybody.
They know how to get by and to beat the,
the,
the most evolved version of you that you can be mean.
It's not like a,
a magical checklist and you talk to people about it.
You said,
okay,
here you got a person you want to improve them.
What are the things that are going to do that?
Okay.
Well,
if I was at life coach,
the first thing I would say is this guy's got to get on a diet that makes them
healthy.
I don't need to die just to lose weight.
I mean,
just healthy food in your body needs many,
many vegetables,
vegetables,
a lot of good,
good quality protein,
a lot of water.
Stop the sodas.
Stop the bullshit.
Start working out your body and get a better sense of like Kubus machine feels
when it's moving,
it's flowing better.
There's less tension in it.
Your mind feels like we are lax than enjoy every single moment of the day.
Better step one and putting those that stuff right.
What's step two?
Be Cool to be relaxed is when people come to smile as many cables,
you can have them smile back at you.
Tip.
Well,
when you go to a restaurant,
it just do the most.
You can be as nice as you can,
you know,
and it just still,
we manage five people walk.
Just get through the assignment.
What else?
Do what you want to do with your life,
right?
Don't,
don't go be doing something you don't enjoy or don't do something.
Don't get locked into,
you know,
a car they can afford and doing something crazy.
If you can need the modeling phone,
do what you want to look for,
fuck days you really want to do because if someone else is doing it,
you can do it.
You know?
I mean everybody makes their own path through this world,
but a lot of people don't follow them path that the real fucking deal.
Hope to the now because for whatever reason you've got negative programming,
you know,
when they're a kid,
someone told them to do it or total to take the short Todd or,
or take the,
uh,
the initial route.
That's a sad thing.
That was a little long.
I wisdom.
Very cool though.
It's cool.
It's cool that someone did that.
Whoever
did that.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
What is his name?
No name or no name or,
well,
I should find out,
right?
Well I can't because my cunt sucking website is down.
Cons.
Don't you hate that?
They shouldn't.
There's no reason for that.
My website's down a lot.
It really is no reason for that.
So I refer to my website is [inaudible] crazy.
Yeah.
This fucking things and as Shit,
I dunno what's happening.
Perhaps it's a dos attack.
Brian,
perhaps we're being attacked by hackers.
Um,
thank you very much for tuning into the podcast.
I'm sorry we're late,
but you know,
shit happens.
We're not very good at starting these things on time.
That's the beautiful thing about the internet and you don't really have to start
everything on time.
Yeah.
Do we have an echo going on the background?
It seems like we do.
Don't we go see if that shit is on?
I think it is.
I can't get this right.
I swear to God.
We try and try every week.
That's why you're supposed to have like,
but if you
had an engineer here,
what if he was a Weirdo?
You see the big circular thing,
Brian,
do you see it?
Yeah.
I just,
you tell him no,
you didn't see that big circular thing.
Touch it and it shuts off.
Okay.
Did you do that middle Starbuck?
Yes.
No,
no,
no.
It's,
it's fuck.
Just shut it off to shut their computer off.
Yes,
there we go.
God,
what kind of a show is this?
We have to listen to this.
Ladies and gentlemen,
what I subjected you to,
I apologize.
The best shows are always that word.
Wonder what the fuck.
We're just justifying the fact that we're completely unprofessional.
This show has all are sponsored by the fleshlight laser.
Gentlemen,
if you have not fucked one,
do you do not know what you're missing.
I think that's an official slogan.
Now,
keep it away from teething dog.
Outstanding masturbation device.
Mr. Coleman,
I suggest you use one.
I actually have one for you.
I appreciate that.
I hope my hopes you have.
Yeah,
I got it.
I got one that I saved.
Especially for you.
Thank you.
It's um,
dress it up as a beer can apparently.
Nice.
Or is it pussy and now here it looks like a can.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
So like if you're a closet pervert,
so he gets to be,
you got this out,
you gotta you gotta do some weeks played it.
It's worth more if you don't turn it.
Take off the plastic though.
Why is that?
Because it's like more of a collector's item unit.
Fuck.
Are you talking about what makes you say a baseball card?
Dude?
It's a fake pussy collecting fake pussy.
That is the craziest thing you've ever said.
Don't want to,
should could be [inaudible] natural light.
You snapped me out of it.
I hate that.
What is it about people that are in the like collecting old shit like that and
keeping it in the wrapper?
This is the exact way it was made.
I used to do that with comic book cars.
Dude cars go for a fuck load of money.
Like old like corvette,
like original corvette,
some stamps and they want original.
Everybody wants original radio,
they want original steering wheel.
All the stuff that sucked.
They want all that stuff.
I think it's a,
it's that feeling of nostalgia.
It's like that you get to touch what was,
you know,
alive back then there.
It was so cool with kind of brings it brings them back to other memories or
something.
It's a very strange just the knee collect.
There's always kind of remind me of people that do other weird stuff.
It's a form.
It's a fetish.
I ain't even comic books.
When you collect your,
it's a fetish now.
It could be stamped but it could also be like fingers.
You know what I mean?
But have you ever done comic books?
Didn't used to do common?
Yes,
I used to do comic books,
read them,
but I would never collect.
It was one of my saddest moments of poverty when I was living in Boston and I
was totally,
I sold all my comic books,
did the exact same thing for rent.
Dude,
mine,
he didn't even barely cover my rent and it was boxes and boxes of comic books
mean they totally fuck you on the money.
Like if they're worth way more than they pay you for it.
But you got to do it.
You got to do like 300 issues.
Just the amazing spider man.
And I had every single macfarlane.
I had like 10 of a topic.
Violence.
First Time you did Spiderman.
I had weird a comic book tastes like I w I liked Conan.
I last cause he's a real person.
I used to read his real book.
Did I write everything?
Robert Frank presented it.
Oh fuck.
Those were the red.
Every single book he ever wrote,
and then he killed himself.
He was a young guy,
killed himself.
He 30 and 30 years old,
so awesome that you're into Robert De,
oh my God.
He's actually a great writer.
I don't know anybody is rider.
That kind of fantasy writing.
He was the best dog.
He created a whole world.
I got the books.
We'll start with this epic battles,
this giant Sumerian,
just this guy with this volcanic glue eyes.
Finally,
some survival will turn and say,
who are you?
And he would say,
Hi,
I'm Colin.
Nice.
Yeah,
Dude.
The didn't looks like him.
That was the heartbreak.
Yeah.
It was very sad.
Set yourself up to such a golden standard.
That's traumatic for our Conan.
Yeah.
That's a invoice for,
is to realize,
I'm never going to be a superhero man.
I'm going to be a go kills dragons with a sword height.
I'm not even going to carry a soy.
They're illegal shit.
I can't carry a story.
They could make the Conan books into a real movie like with a really smart
director,
like instead of like,
like the Conan,
like Arnold sports thing.
It was pretty cool.
It wasn't bad man,
but it was so eighties you know what I'm saying?
You've got a movie that was done like based like,
like with the Hobbit,
Peter Jackson to do it or something.
Get them to really invest in Conan.
Conan was like this freak warrior that just always an epic.
It was always,
he was like,
oh,
they were awesome store Ernie.
And he always learned something at the end of the book,
which was that,
you know steel makes right.
Isn't it fascinating man that,
that dude who wrote it,
Robert Howard's was just completely depressed.
Yeah.
Kill himself in the car.
I believe shot himself in his car.
He's just fucking couldn't take it,
just want it off the planet wanted off.
This guy was like,
well one,
I mean for that genre,
one of the best writers ever.
Really Fun stuff,
man.
Really cool stuff to read.
I love that shit when I was a kid,
but he also,
he lived in that fantasy world and I guess you know,
did Conan Fuck Rid Sonia?
It was that like,
I'm sure he for dating the same girl,
by the way,
if he met her,
he fucked her for sure.
Correct.
100% if he met her,
she just jumped on his dick like it was a grenade he shoes at immediately.
She was a brave soldier.
Yeah.
Listen man,
that's Conan.
Conan was the king of the world.
They're just like the baddest motherfucker ever.
That was the best thing about the Conan series.
Like you knew,
no matter what,
just settle down,
son calling him.
Got It.
He got this.
What was the worst part of their Conan series?
What was the part of Conan that you hated though?
I didn't know nothing about nothing.
Perfectly ready.
You know,
really.
He used to pray to Chrom,
which was the,
the center of the earth.
And you know what he used to ask Krom cause you couldn't ask Krom.
You couldn't ask for forgiveness because he was up restless.
God.
The only thing he ever asked chrom of was a fighting chance.
He just wanted a chance.
They'd just give me a sliver of tie.
Well,
yeah,
I want to die.
Well,
yeah,
that's what every man [inaudible] son to be brave in the face of fucking evil
demons and shit.
Yeah.
Every man's fantasy is to be a hero.
Every man's spirit.
And he's a coward.
He got it all locked up,
man.
He had it all locked up in his brain.
You know,
his,
his depressed brain,
he created this intense fucking fantasy world.
Yeah.
And because in a way,
what he was talking about is somewhat timeless.
You know,
it's almost like just energy.
Like you found a path for it,
you know,
the depression for whatever,
it was fucked up in his life.
He figured out a way to divert it in this other direction,
this huge fantastical world.
You know,
this fantastic world of fucking monsters in witchcraft and sword battles in this
fucking gigantic brawny Tan Brown skin man,
fucking just slaughtering people.
He used to call it,
he used to call it cutting a path of crimson cutting set path.
He used stars and yeah,
he had to have to survive in the fucking woods by eating pigeons,
thrown rocks at him and eaten them.
Ron share some of those stories were awesome.
Yeah,
I just go to the supermarket,
dammit.
Those doors or foods,
those stores where the shit they really were when I was a kid,
I used to do a magic tricks.
I had a little magic show in fisherman's wharf and I would do it.
So I get money for comic books too.
Like yeah,
put on a show.
I was like eight years old and I used to put on a wig and do some dancing.
I saw all these street performers in San Francisco and um,
I got a co like a um,
a box,
like the magic box,
you know,
like for Christmas it's like,
a bunch of card tricks and bunch of shit in it.
So I brought the box of man.
I said,
I know what I'll do.
I'll get a cape,
I'll put a hat,
all acute.
Like I was aware I would look cute.
It was like eight,
and I was like a little eight year old criminal.
That's great.
Hustler.
Yeah.
And so that's how I first,
uh,
started performing really for comic books because I was addicted to comic books
and said,
what did you,
what kind of magic would you do?
It was terrible.
There was only thing,
it was cute because I was eight and I was by myself
till some,
uh,
here's the question.
Older kids bullied me and I got scared me.
If I could give you one magical quality one,
what would it be?
What does it say?
Date
is this ridiculous date with a contrived,
obviously it would be for [inaudible] to be a palm reader cause he's a date with
a guy who believes in crystals.
What happened?
A guy who believes in crystals.
I'm a healer.
And if you could have one super power,
what
would it be?
I don't know,
man.
Uh,
if I really could think about,
I want to look like one of those miles stat cows at first.
I want to say flying,
but I'm so afraid of heights.
I feel like fly above this sky wouldn't matter.
You'd get.
I get somewhere,
I guess 15 minutes early.
Is there really that and how many places to really be?
Not really and you wouldn't fly?
I'd be all sweaty.
Seems cool.
But then the head with birds and bugs,
it's hard to take magic powers serious after you've had a real good mushroom
trip.
Yeah.
Magic powers.
Like DMT is way crazier than any fucking magic trick anybody could ever do.
What if I could?
What if I said to you,
you could see five minutes into the future for every time you were kind of on a
five minutes.
That'd be great and everything,
but then you'd be this at Douche bag who just knew about everything and
everybody else surprises.
Like you try to tell people and they're like,
how do you know?
How come I don't know that people would hate on you?
Believe me,
man.
The last thing you'd want to know is the future.
What if,
why didn't you tell me I was going to die?
You know,
my father could have been saved as you told us not to get on the train.
Yeah.
But what if you could change the future as a result,
we then change everything man.
And what do you do?
Are you going to keep people alive forever?
You lose it.
Venture will,
not only that,
but the reality is this is a temporary experience.
We know it.
It's on paper.
It's been proven.
It's documented.
I like to,
I really liked what you were saying about,
um,
and that thing we just listened to about how people know,
they really do know the answers of how to take care of themselves.
Yeah.
It's getting out of their own way.
And it's always what I,
it brings me back to like what I always talk about when you have like mayor
Bloomberg and wants to outlaw trans fats and food or,
or you know,
when,
when Washington or any government agency wants to legislate good health,
whether it's making drugs to make people dumber,
well it's,
you're not gonna,
you're not gonna make people healthier people.
People know the answer.
There are a lot of really smart people that smoke.
You can't run,
you can't pull out fatty food shit,
but they're doing it.
It,
it doesn't mean they don't know it's bad for him.
It's a very,
there's a whole nother question.
It's why are people,
why are people,
why don't people dare to be the best they can be?
Why it is because it takes effort?
Or is it more of a courages issue?
Are you afraid of what you might find or not find as a result?
You know,
that's,
that's really the question.
Yeah.
There's a lot of distractions going on with us.
You know,
people sabotage themselves all the time.
I see it all the time.
Yeah.
You create all sorts of bad habits so you don't have to deal with your own
bullshit,
you know?
But,
um,
I'm all for personal choice,
man.
I think it's very important that we encourage personal choice.
Absolutely.
Appreciate it much more if you earn it.
You know,
I'm writing this book and one of the things that I wrote about this book that
the only thing I'm really proud of,
of anything that I've ever done in my life is my peace of mind like that.
I know that I worked on that.
I know that I got there because I grew up in a very fucked up tor turmoil filled
life and I figured out a way to navigate it to become a happy person.
It's like one of the only things that I'm proud of.
Yeah,
I think,
I think that knowing you for as long as I've known you,
which is going on 16 years,
I think that's a huge,
I absolutely see that transformation because you used to be so intense and used
to look at the world is I think as just full of barbs and thorns,
you know,
and you were always on the defensive.
Always read.
Cause I remember we'd be,
we'd be hanging out and somebody would say something stupid.
What you role is run into and and I,
and you just,
it was so hard for you to,
you just,
you
just immediately call them out on their ridiculous.
A two plus two is 15 and Unicorns live in my backyard and I'd go that's great.
And you go ball shit,
I don't like this person.
And I'd be like,
ah,
what do I do with this uncomfortable confrontation?
He used to hang out with some knuckleheads though in all fair.
I really did all fairness.
We're hanging out with some crazy people,
truly,
and I am not that way with reasonable rational people,
but when I'm there with meth heads and I know someone's a meth head and I'm
like,
um,
something's wrong here,
I smell stop.
This is not normal conversation we're having here.
We've got it.
We got an issue where we're not going to deal with how crazy this bitches and
I'd be like,
I can't say anything.
We would be out with one of Brian's friends that it would occur to be like five
minutes in the conversation.
Okay,
this is like a crazed fucking half home was criminal.
We're hanging out with and I'm like,
okay,
we have to deal with this.
Nah,
she's cool.
She's just a little nervous today.
She no,
she gets weird around people.
Yeah,
you're in intense guy.
She gets weird here.
She,
she's,
she's just start,
start.
Just starstruck.
Like she's doing meth fucking mind,
Bro.
I'm like,
this is a,
there's a monster disconnect here with this.
Check you out.
I really did find meth in her purse.
And meanwhile she ruined my life.
Yeah,
it was a wreck.
I try Brock come out of it.
Do you remember when I was younger?
I'd think I'd be like,
oh,
that girl comes from a nice family.
I'll take the go with the bat tattooed on her,
on her face,
and the track marks.
Bruises.
How crazy.
This girl was crazy.
This was w uh,
Brian and I met her at a bar and uh,
he told me,
I want you to meet this girl been seeing.
And she's really cool.
So I go and I meet him at the bar.
I talked to her for three,
four seconds,
three or four seconds,
she turns and walks away.
And I looked at him and I go,
she's fucking crazy.
I go,
that girl is crazy.
let's get Outta here right now.
I go,
get the fuck outta here.
you need to just change your numbers.
Shut your fucking phone off.
Let's go.
Let's get out of here.
I was like,
Nah,
she's fine.
She's cool.
Now,
you know,
you have a friend who you love to death,
but for some reason like he doesn't have those John Carpenter glasses from them
thing.
He can't fucking see it.
Everybody else can see that this bitch is crazy.
He could not see it.
He just,
he did not just chose not to say it would,
you didn't just choose not to see,
you would glaze over and become like locked into this is a project for me,
whether I'm trying to help her,
I want to change her.
And I was like crazy a survival boy.
I was like,
we gotta get Outta here.
You are.
But you were always right.
Cause I would have saved a lot of effort and time.
You're a healer,
Brian.
I don't have healer instincts.
I have,
I have runaway from monster and the healing your instincts are phoning to,
because what I was trying to do is just,
I just wanted a project where it was like I was the guy of the savior.
It was very selfish and Eh,
uh,
arrange,
blamed himself.
I mean you're being critical,
but assuming it was selfish,
but it was just,
it's just a faction of all of these things,
all these crazy behaviors or just from our childhood.
That's all it is.
Yeah.
I think you're right.
That's what it is.
I mean,
you did not like the way you were raised and you were trying to literally raise
a chick.
Right.
You were trying to literally guide them.
I mean,
I know and fuck them and fuck them.
I mean that.
That's important.
That's part of the guidance.
A huge part of the guys and stuff on his stomach and part of the keynote.
Your bad universe.
Yeah.
Such an ad.
Fuck them and fuck them.
What a crazy fucking,
it occurred to me.
I remember when I told you this occurred to me that the girls I was dating in
La,
I was like,
I like,
I looked at like the last four relationships and I was like,
wow,
all for relationships.
All of those girls for me,
they were all essentially a high tech pet.
They were not people.
They were high tech pets had to feed them.
I had to,
I had to be nice to them and pet them.
I had to go,
I had to talk to them like a little curious and that I had to fuck them.
And who hasn't thrown a wig on a dog?
The point age.
It's all about hacking them.
Oh my God.
It's so true.
It was weird.
Well,
his current women aside,
she's very nice and he's had a few in the past.
They were very nice.
It's not all of them.
You know,
Patty Jenkins is one of the coolest humans on the planet.
No doubt.
Uh,
but Brian has like been the smartest guy that I know that is dated the dumbest
checks.
I mean,
just struck,
just dumb,
crazy straight.
Just,
just tell my girl,
my girl,
my girl Tina,
who,
uh,
I lived with Nick and she thought she didn't know who Freud was.
She didn't know Freud was,
she was 30.
And then she thought,
and she was,
this was an actress.
She thought that Shakespeare lived in biblical times.
I was like,
Hey,
you're already at my house.
How do I go through this?
Eviction?
Took a year.
Oh my.
See if I can procrastinate the ending of this for the next two years.
Wow.
Well,
you know what,
there's nothing wrong with not knowing something.
Well,
yeah.
I just get older though and you seems like you should know that thing is to get
older and learn,
learn from your mistakes and not make the same ones.
You know?
The problem is a lot of people get programmed a certain way as they're growing
up and it's very hard to shake off their programming.
Sometimes it's better to have no programming as I think you did and I did,
where you just kinda were left alone to figure out life by yourself.
Sometimes I think that's better than having shitty programming because of a girl
grows up a shitty programming where there's a lot of dumb people around her all
the time offering they're dumb thoughts and she's with dumb people all day
instead of being left alone.
I think the,
the reason that I didn't grow up that way necessarily is I lived in so many
different countries.
I was always,
I was always literally moved.
I thought about it.
By the time I,
I,
this is a true,
this is true.
I didn't live anywhere for more than for the first 30 years of my life,
actually 33 years of my life.
I didn't live in one place for more than a year and a half.
I literally moved every year to year and a half and a lot of times it was a
totally different culture,
continent,
but I think didn't allow me to get pigeon holed or B,
I was exposed to so many different cultures and ideas that you have to kind of
keep reshifting and adjusting your paradigm cause what,
what you,
what you think is a preconceived notion.
For example,
you know,
you get this idea of what a lot of people will say,
well that's my idea of what an Arab is.
That's my idea of what a Jew is.
It's my idea of whatever,
whatever it is.
When you're exposed constantly to different people in totally different
settings,
what you really actually learned to do as a child to empathize with those people
because you start to realize,
yeah,
they're different,
but they're exactly the same.
Did you find
yourself being a chameleon and blending into the new entity?
My Dad used to say,
my father said to me when I was,
I'm going to say,
he said I was 15 and he said,
I've never seen anyone ever be a bigger chameleon.
They said,
your ability to ingratiate yourself and find your way into any situation and
find a hole in any situation.
He said,
I remember him telling his first comment he ever gave me.
He never even gave me a comment.
He said this,
it's,
it's remarkably because I've never seen anything like it in my life.
He saw me like I was in Switzerland or something and I just had no friends and
everything was a chameleon.
We moved from New Jersey to San Francisco to Florida.
To Boston.
Yeah,
and that's why your accents,
by the way,
a lot of people don't know one thing about you.
Your accidents are as good as anybody's and that's probably because you
developed an ear.
Well,
I learned rhythm about my icing.
I won the Bay State Games Taekwondo Tournament and they put me on television was
the first one was on top and I was 19 and I heard myself on TV.
I was talking about my instructor,
Mr. Michael Mallory,
and I was saying,
me and Mr O'malley,
we've been working out really hard and uh,
and I,
I heard my accent,
I was like,
dad is the gross,
this fucking thing I've ever heard in my life.
I had like a fake Boston accent.
I mean,
I had a Boston accent.
Yeah,
you said I was so disappointed in myself that I picked it up that quickly.
I only lived in Boston for like three years and all of a sudden I had this crazy
accent.
But that comes,
I think from having an ear for,
for the music of any situations by then,
six years by then,
then I'd be in Boston.
But six years in a developed like a hot hot.
Sure.
That's ridiculous.
We're social animals though too,
you know.
So I dropped it.
I learned and I dropped it.
I had hearing myself on TV maybe like consider my accent,
like how ridiculous it was.
I was like affecting an accent set to fit in.
Is it ever come out of the blue though?
Like are you in Boston for sure.
I mean I lived in Boston.
Boston is where I grew up.
If you know,
you talk about my formative years,
my formative years or 13 to 24 I lived in Boston 13 to 23 something like that.
It's a long time.
That's time your boss.
That's the,
that's grown up.
That's my,
I mean if I think about a hometown,
Boston something was a rough town by the way.
Isn't this funny?
We just had the UFC in Boston.
There was no less than like 11 bench clearing brawls in the fucking stands.
I mean like full on soccer kicks,
pride style.
There's stories on the Internet of people getting their fucking head stomped and
there's all kinds of crazy story or not.
So this was at the UFC.
In the stands there aren't many fights filled with,
yes,
they're savages.
Amazing.
I've never lived in a place where people were so quick to scrap.
It's why a lot of good comics come out of Boston though,
because to be able to deal with those crowds as cynical crowds and navigate your
way through that.
Yeah,
we've talked about it on this show many,
many times with with other Boston guys like bill burr and Dane Cook,
and it's,
it's the place where,
you know,
it's like the proving ground for comedy.
There was so many good comics that came out of there.
So that's one of the reasons,
like you had to be so on your toes to make those guys laugh.
And if you,
if they turned on you,
it was over.
If you know,
if a Boston crowd turns in,
you starts billing,
there's no rational thinking involved.
Like if you go on stage with a fucking Yankee shirt on,
they're just going to start throwing shit at you.
We're not going to talk about this.
Hey,
come on
guys.
I like New York.
You like Pasta.
What's a big deal?
Fuck you.
They'll fucking throw glasses that you didn't give me shit.
They'll all together decide to beat the fuck out of you.
It won't be like,
like one guy does it and the other.
Yeah.
The other people go,
hey,
we shouldn't do this.
No,
they don't go.
Yeah.
Get 'em the way a school of fish knows to turn to,
they'll break your windows if you're driving by with a New York license plate on
your car,
like they're fucking crazy.
Guys haven't even read God in his autobiography.
Yeah,
but there's something about that.
That town has a great sense of humor.
Man.
I noticed the truth in a way.
You know,
it's like you can't be it.
You can't bullshit your way into Boston.
Yes.
You show up in a pair of leather pants.
Hey guys,
I just bought these limits and stuff.
Fuck.
Is he doing?
Heck,
kick those off quick.
I told you I,
my buddy carbon pro,
my provost,
not on New York's,
a little bit like that I,
I bought,
I've been in Paris and this woman,
this,
this really sexy sales woman told me that I looked like Arnold Schwarzenegger in
this leather jacket and I was like,
I do.
I must've gotten,
I literally like I've hurt myself on,
I must,
I think I put on muscle mass in Paris.
Like I literally,
this is what an idiot I am.
This how badly I've always wanted to be built.
Like,
like a guy like that.
So I go,
I'll buy the jacket.
And it was,
at the time it was like $400 I did not have any money.
I was like,
that's ridiculous.
Shows you'll know.
It would go really well.
I was like Quoc in French.
She goes,
these leather pants.
And of course I'm like,
oh,
that's exactly what's missing from my life.
I'm really going to get girls.
By the way,
I wasn't 60 that was like 24 so I literally show up.
I literally,
oh,
by the way,
I bought,
I had to get boots that went with them because they didn't really fit.
So I had these boots that go with these pants and these chocolate chocolate
milk,
chocolate leather,
thick leather pants.
Not Suede fucking leather.
Okay.
Like couch leather.
So my buddies,
Eddie man,
only way,
way too much.
They were so thick I couldn't run to thorn brier and being fine.
Really?
Yeah,
really.
They were literally,
I remember them being so thick.
I was like trying to get into him.
I was supposed to stretch him.
It was a disaster and literally I walk out and my buddies,
I think Karma and Eddie Mccann,
Donnie Gannon,
I mean all of these like Irish and Italian
guys.
From there,
it kind of goes,
what the fuck is,
he got on his legs and I'm like,
oh,
these are,
these are from before he even got Paris out,
they were on me pulling my pants off.
So just getting them off me to throw out the window.
Yeah,
we fucked,
oh,
sorry.
Sorry.
I,
I mean I erase.
Erase.
Is this on the delay?
Yeah.
Yeah,
we got it,
dude.
Imagine if that's all people wore.
Just animal skins.
If that's my,
that's my joke.
I'm always like,
yeah,
that's a soft,
what is that now?
First Girls Go,
where'd you buy that?
I'm like,
buy it.
I caught it,
killed it and made it.
Oh my God.
It's so fucking soft.
I'll kind of phrase that puppy.
Oh,
that's me.
But they had chicken heads.
We,
it was pretty funny until that.
And then the kids,
that's what I do.
And then I,
and then I go,
yeah,
but if they,
but you know what?
I would never do that.
But they're just,
they're easy to catch horrible video online where those four Chan guys are after
that bitch,
that bitch fuck put your happy face.
A chick who had a bucket full of puppies,
man.
And she walks up to a river and starts throwing the puppies in the water.
The puppies are Yiping.
Where did it take place?
What country?
Ah,
fuck.
I can't remember.
No.
What country you can find it.
But four Chan is Internet.
You know,
it's a website filled with fucking site website.
Love weight website.
[inaudible] website on the road.
Joe,
funny shit that comes out of it,
man.
What's a website?
Four Chan.
That's where all the lll cat meme all came from that,
you know,
there's really hilarious cats.
Stupid like almost ebonics shit.
It's all from says what you know,
like the NDC.
It'd be like,
it's funny in the thread,
one of the best websites ever.
That's the,
one of the funnest thing about the internet is he's a little fucking Nigga.
You Gay,
no window motor shops in a fucking lake.
Gregory occurring jerk though.
But joke though,
like people will save them and you know,
and you'll find them online.
Like there's a lot of really funny ones that you can this man,
you know,
this thread smells gay,
and someone was spraying Lysol on the one thing.
No tip.
If you go to four Chan's website,
put it on private surfing mode on your browser or just clear cache and delete
your computer when you're done going to that website because you'll see some
crazy shit at that way.
So what you think is a lot of illegal stuff.
I mentioned that we don't want anybody getting locked up in the pokey.
Just be careful just because you hear about this website.
Um,
I was just at parlor live in Seattle by the way.
That's a great club.
Um,
have you ever done that parlor la live in Seattle?
No,
I've only done the underground,
that small place on the distance to place.
They pack it in.
I did a theater there,
they pack it in and it's run by this Guy Ruben.
And um,
it's,
it's probably,
uh,
like a solid 300 but,
but it's a smart group cause they're all Microsoft people.
They're all from,
it's really cool.
It's up in Bellevue where like Microsoft temporary.
Really?
Yeah.
You get like a really cool,
kind of like eclectic but pretty educated audience.
So it's kind of,
I don't know,
it's kind of refreshing.
I that I've talking about San Francisco.
Yeah man.
And so,
uh,
anyway,
but the,
the,
the one of the comics that was there,
um,
poor girl,
she,
she was married and found out her husband was having an affair.
And the reason she found out was because there's a website called Dolly Madison
or something for married people if they want to have the stairs.
Yeah.
Holly Madison.
Madison.
Yeah.
Holly Madison.
And she,
and she had a,
and he had a,
his profile on there,
you know,
it's like way to get caught through.
And she was like,
she was like,
ah,
my husband's on the looking for,
this is weird.
Loud.
You know how hilarious is that that someone came up with a website for people
that want to cheat?
Yeah.
For other emergencies.
So many people would cheat on other married people.
Again,
it's like,
Hey,
I'm married.
You're married to let's go back.
Crazy.
Great.
That's scary.
It was scary that these go so dumb that he would create a fucking profile with
his real name.
Yeah.
With his real name and picture.
Hey,
he put his pictures outside my profiles.
I want to get caught that go.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
come on.
Did you see that Twitter that I put out the other day about there was a website
using html 5.0 and it's called the wilderness downtown.com somebody else did you
do it?
No,
it's check it out.
The wilderness,
downtown.com you put in your address like I like the place you grew up in and
what it does is it takes Google like street view maps and it mixes it with like,
like videos of people running down streets and it shows like aerial views
zooming into your house.
Like it's like in a helicopter and it just uses it from like this one address
and it's fucking trippy.
I mean it's not,
it's cool after like a few minutes you'd get the tricks and everything like
that.
But at first you're sitting there going,
wow,
this is bad ass.
So check it out.
It's the wilderness downtown just preparing us.
Yeah,
they're premier preparing us for the one state of total connectivity.
The whole fucking world is corrected.
Takes up.
It's called the singularity.
That's they call called Cartwheel,
right?
Yeah.
The idea that there's going to come [inaudible] cubs right near all global hub.
Well,
I think that's one of the thing,
one of the reasons why people hate deception so much that people hate lies so
much is that we were,
you know,
everyone's trying to figure life out.
And it doesn't help if you find out that someone's not being honest,
like you can help me,
you your revelations.
And they have,
you know,
we,
you and I have talked a bunch of times about some crazy shit.
Yeah.
And helped each other very much.
And the reason why is because I absolutely believe that you're going to tell me
the truth and you know that I'm going to tell you the truth.
If you don't have that,
if one person is telling the truth and the other person isn't,
then you fucked.
Didn't.
You're in this weird situation like,
oh,
this guy's not even looking at reality.
This is bullshit.
He's not helping me.
He's actually hindering me.
It's getting in the way.
I see that.
But I see that all the time when often to find,
I find tiring about living in Los Angeles and maybe I'm being fair or unfair.
Dot.
Los Angeles.
Maybe it's everywhere.
But I just always find that people are not only playing a character,
they're not against themselves.
Yes,
they're,
they,
they haven't even faced up to who they are because they're still,
they're still playing a character.
How,
how common is,
are these characters that they're clearly defined right there.
The actors are so clearly defined because they're almost archetypes.
They're like,
this is what a man is supposed to behave like.
So this is how I'm going to behave.
And by the way,
this is also how my wife is going to be at.
My woman's going to be here.
So you have to amended a woman playing characters and coming together on almost
a f uh,
uh,
it just,
the platform by which they're coming together is already,
is already fake.
Nobody's being honest with,
you know,
you've been Kansas guy who's gotta be toe and this way and she's been cast as
this other person.
It's like watching a show.
Yeah.
You know,
I've,
I've watched,
I watch people like actors talk at a party and it literally is like,
they're appearing on an episode of friends right there.
Say everything they're saying is affected and fake and there's like a certain
quality to it a certain way.
You know,
I hate when people say good to see you.
You know why they say good to see you?
Because they can't remember if they met you or not.
You know,
they say good to see you.
And it's like,
it's creepy actor political thinking thing where I say,
if I said Nice to meet you,
and someone goes,
oh,
we met already.
I'm like,
I'm sorry,
I'm a retard.
When do we meet?
Like I just can't,
I just can't remember everybody.
That's just the problem.
It's like there's only a certain amount of hard drive space that human being has
in his head for people.
Right?
They say it's like 150 people.
Right,
right.
There's like been calculations done on it.
Like at 150 people,
you can't remember anybody motor,
you don't have the space for it.
I want to piggy back what you're saying on a,
and on this,
this quote I heard from Eleanor Roosevelt and she said,
she said,
um,
a mediocre minds talk about people elevated.
Mine's talk about events and great minds talk about ideas.
And so when you're talking about having a hard drive for certain,
um,
for,
for people,
you're not supposed to even aspire to talk about people.
Think about what most people talk about.
Look a little bit,
pay attention to the conversations.
And you know what you'll find most of the time they're gossiping.
They're telling stories about other people,
sort of shortcomings or point.
It's why US magazine,
those magazines are so popular.
It's why so many of these talk shows that deal only with what's going on in
Hollywood are so successful.
Uh,
people want to,
they want to,
um,
they want it.
I'm always amazed at people's capacity for gossip and how people can actually
give a shit about somebody's relationship if they happen to be in a movie.
And stuff like that.
Story's too,
though.
Everyone's always done that.
Back in the day you had stories,
good stories.
It's to our detriment.
It's serious.
There's serious things going on in the world that,
that raised very serious questions,
right?
We're all affected by it.
And,
and it seems to me almost this sort of,
um,
uh,
I don't know if the word is,
um,
this,
eh,
analgesics,
sort of a quality to sitting back and talking about things that have nothing to
do with anything that are by their very nature,
completely ethereal.
For example,
like how much weight this actress lost or how much weight this actress gained
and things like that.
Do you ever
watch keeping up with the Kardashians?
I do not.
I think you should get it up.
It's really a good show.
I can't wait.
Hope they have the CD.
I have a theory about all this stuff,
this stuff,
you know,
gossiping and Shit.
I think what it really is is,
uh,
you know,
human beings.
I think it has a sort of a therapeutic effect on people.
I think the questions that are around us all the time are so big and so scary
and so slowly it of course it's a form of connection.
And I'm not talking about,
I'm not talking about connection.
I'm not talking about having a place for everything like that.
I'm,
I'm saying that the problem is that when that is,
when that becomes all people think and talk about there's something wrong when
there are other,
there are things that are allowed.
A lot of what's going on is I think people are inundated with too much data.
I think people,
there's there,
our brains are not set up to be on the Internet yet.
It's just the brain is just being overwhelmed by shit.
So I think we like to keep things really simple sometimes to distract ourselves
from that.
Well that's an instinct thing too because I was also thinking about how
technology and its exponential growth is kind of rendering masculinity in its
traditional form.
Completely obsolete.
Someone sent me an email thanking me.
He goes,
thank you for connecting rational thinking and manly shit together because
normally it doesn't exist.
And he goes,
most people aren't open minded.
You know,
if you're into manly shit,
like everyone assumes you're a meathead,
you're a dumb ass.
You can't enjoy it.
I can't be intelligent and enjoy this,
but I do.
So what's going on?
It's in my nature.
How can you tell me I'm wrong in your genes?
I mean,
how can you tell someone they're wrong with that?
But it's interesting how a lot of this stuff is becoming simulated.
One of the reasons I think video games are so popular is because it's a,
it's an outlet.
It's an aggressive outlet for,
for,
for boys and men even to exercise that natural instinct to Hudson Killaly
natural man.
We're were fleeing.
Ricky Schroder was a on a couple of weeks ago,
two weeks ago,
and a Ricky like hunts like crazy.
He's like,
yeah,
he's a,
he would never strike everything man.
He hunts everything and we were talking about like hunter gatherer instincts and
it brought up the idea and I brought this up.
I think there's probably be like a series of genetic rewards we have for like
catching an eating things and killing things because it's good for you and
because something is good for you,
usually there's like some sort of a natural award system going on.
Like with,
you know,
your brain chemistry,
you get like,
you know,
a little blast of dopamine or whatever happens,
a little blast of something.
And we were talking about it and we were talking about like fishing.
Like you ever go fishing man and catch a big fish and then cook and eat whole,
it feels doubly right.
Yeah,
I should,
yeah.
I think we're getting away from all that stuff and we all have these reward
systems that are set up inside of our bodies and if we don't get them in some
direction and forced them into like a good exercise or,
or,
or some fucking creative path or something like,
we're basically making up for some rewards that we don't get all day anymore.
You know,
our lives now,
if you work a shitty job,
even if it pays well,
if it's a Shitty,
boring ass fucking job,
it's not nearly as exciting as being a hunter.
Right.
You know,
you're a hunter,
you know,
you might not be successful everyday,
but there's some shit's going to go down.
You've got to stock and you've gotta look out for other animals.
We're trying to jack you.
Yeah.
You know,
you got all keep an eye out for mountain lions and crazy shit.
I mean,
if we're talking about like thousands and thousands of years ago,
we still have those bodies.
We still have those bodies that are wired like sex feels good.
Why?
So you make babies.
It's set up for that.
The hunt feels good.
Why?
So?
You keep hunting.
There's just a walk reward system.
So there's a deficit because we're not experiencing that.
We're not,
even though we do have decks and we do have balls,
we are men like in society.
Like there's,
there's very little outlets.
I'm saying,
does that vary?
There are very few outlets.
You know,
you can't,
you can't [inaudible] to kill Shit.
Right?
We are designed to hunt for thousands of years.
I mean,
for a millennia,
we've been genetically programmed to provide and protect and which takes courage
and cutting.
And as long as we're eating meat,
okay,
if you're eating meat,
that means you're killing something.
Right?
And if you're killing something,
you have to be violent.
There's gotta be a violent release and,
and all of a sudden you're taking in all this animal poison like to tell you or
not,
but there is no violence with most of us.
There's no release.
There's no explosion.
That's,
that's why everybody is fucking crazy with stress,
right?
We're eating meat and not being viable.
You had said,
you were all saying exercise.
I saw.
I so believe that that the first thing for anybody to do in my opinion is
getting your body.
Yes.
Get in it and feel the machine and,
and exercise I think is,
is uh,
is crucial.
It's a,
yeah,
it's maintenance for the mind,
the body.
It's important,
but it's the mind.
You can think way better.
If I have anything that's fucking with me.
I go out and I hit the punching bag.
I just think about nothing.
Just hit the punching pack,
kick you punch it.
Kinda tend to do a few rounds and nothing bothers me when it's over.
I heard a statistic and I,
I don't know,
I don't know.
I don't have the,
it's not like Mayo Clinic and stuff,
but it was,
it came from a fairly reliable source.
Um,
that said that one in four people,
if you know by the one in four people will die of cancer,
but one in four people get cancer eventually,
whether it's in their eighties or nineties,
whatever,
one in seven athletes get cancer they found.
And there there are a couple of theories for that.
What is it?
Exercise,
you know,
moves lymphatic fluid through your body and that's how you keep your body clean
and all that stuff.
But,
and then,
then you know,
people who are,
who did sports,
who are at,
but they're talking about athletes,
I professional athletes and Olympic athletes,
one in seven versus a,
your standard one in fall.
What kind of cancer?
Breast Cancer.
All cancers.
All,
you know,
one interesting statistic that there's never been a professional athlete that
has lived to be over a hundred.
I believe that.
And I think it's probably because of the stress.
I don't know if that's true,
but I read that,
well,
athletes called the,
it was called um,
uh,
dead doctors tell no tales or something like that.
It was all about minerals and well,
from what I understood,
um,
professional athletes,
you know from store at sports do die earlier as well.
It makes sense if you put this incredible amount of stress from your body,
your ass cancer from eating so much like proteins and hard meats and stuff like
that.
Maybe ask,
you have to go straight Brock Lesnar,
you get that one and two closer almost died from diverticulitis.
Is that a liver disease?
So it's from eating too much protein and no fiber,
we don't have yeah,
protein buildup in your,
in your gut.
And it was actually like rotting a hole through it and creating abscesses.
He had like a real problem getting sick or did,
he just doesn't feel good for a long time.
They said that he was operating at 60 to 80% of his potential,
which is fucking terrifying when you think of how fucking fast and strong and
athletic that dude is.
And they think that he was,
he was like actually like sick the whole time.
That's so crazy.
Crushing do today.
Six,
he's fighting Cain Velasquez in October in Los Angeles now in Anaheim and I am
now.
Um,
I've never seen anybody quite so explosive and so big.
I mean he walked around through freak ass.
Doesn't he walk around at 300 pounds and suck down?
Um,
you know,
not anymore.
I don't think he wants to take that toll on his body,
but he's a bit over to 65 is actually lighter now that he's ever been before
because he changed his diet.
Is he stronger when you talk to other guys who fought him?
Does he feel like Dushane who've traveled him say due to Trent?
Well,
you know,
you've got clipped in the big punch.
You know,
Shankar when is so strong,
what the fuck too.
And he can bang dude,
chain car has serious,
serious,
serious power.
He's got power that there's not a single man on the planet that can take one of
those bombs and be okay.
We got fucked up and Brock knew it.
I think he felt it and was like,
Holy Shit,
this is like a new kind of thunderstorm coming my way.
I don't know anybody ever hit him like that.
I mean,
everybody's like,
Brock can't take a shot,
and Brock covered up and ran like no.
Brock survived and won the fight stupid,
which he did with that two took a BD caught clipped.
We knew for sure that Shane was going to be the better striker,
but you know,
Shane has an,
but Brock has had some good,
you know,
like he dropped Randy with a right hand.
He dropped heath herring with a right hand.
It was just how quick Shane put it on him.
It was just as soon as you start a bomb and I'm just like,
oh shit.
It's like,
that dude's got some special power.
He's got something.
Oh,
like he hits dudes and you could see the look in their eyes.
They're like,
what the fuck?
Like when he hit Frank Mir,
like he kicked frank,
we would like to short left hand inside and you could see frank mirs face like a
couple of times before he dropped him.
He hit him with like the short and punches a friend.
It was that,
but it was the look in his face like Whoa,
like this is some fucking rocky shit we're doing here.
Like hammered like these are bombs.
He's seeing sparks to try to keep it together and he's not expecting that.
And then he's thinking,
what happens if this motherfucker gets his arms loose and starts raining the
Zombie?
I'm going to sleep.
And then he gets one the and loose.
I was like,
Oh fuck.
Here it comes.
Boom,
boom.
And when the mirrors legs give out,
I'm like God Damn America,
take a shot man.
He's a big guy who can take a shot because he took a gang of them before he went
out.
He took a gang of them and Carmen was blasting him.
Man,
that's just calling.
If he can get his cardio together,
he can get a situation together.
I think it was a situation with the boss sizer fight.
He got really excited.
He thought it was over.
He thought it was over and he was just going to try to stop the fight and throw
as many punches as possible.
He got,
well,
from what I heard,
he's got,
he got really strategy mistake.
He didn't breathe and he didn't,
you know,
he locked,
he locked up and then he got,
you know,
literally lactic acid froze his muscles in the second round.
He was done.
He can figure out how to get his strategy together and it might not even be the
be that pig man.
I mean,
he's like too,
he was like,
he told me he cut,
I think he said 16 pounds.
Cool.
So when I was talking to him the day of the fight,
he was 16 above to 65 so weird.
How big these guys are so weird.
He's a politician.
He's six one six two.
So weird.
What did he do?
Redonkulous gorilla pause too.
He's just shakes your hand and you're like,
what the fuck is that?
That you call a hair?
What is this?
There's this giant thing,
my question own and you know,
and the ham hock just see,
well,
cause there,
there are bears and their dogs.
I'm a dog and he's a fancy bear no matter what happens,
the dog never be to bear on a fight.
But,
but um,
what,
what my question,
I'm sure you've been asked before is what I noticed about federal,
the Yanco is his timing,
his ability to,
the time punches.
And it's just so much,
it's so much better than everybody else's.
Everybody else in,
he's really good visibility and his speed,
he looks very fast.
Very dope.
Boy,
he's gotta be,
I bet you if he were to really trimmed down,
he's gotta be 25 pounds overweight.
I'm just talking about fat.
I think you're right.
And it's incredible.
It's incredible.
And uh,
I,
you know that,
that's the one thing I'd like to see him fight.
Brock said that I think that he could fight in middleweight and I'm not kidding.
I mean,
I wouldn't want to see him do it.
I,
I enjoy the fact that he fights it.
Heavyweight [inaudible] would stand up to him in middleweight.
I mean,
you know,
I don't know.
I mean who knows,
maybe the speed wouldn't be as big as an advantage at middleweight.
Maybe at middleweight maybe one of the things he's got going for him as he
really is a small guy and you know when he's throwing his punches,
it's sufficient power to drop these guys.
Cause I'll tell you what,
a guy like Patrick [inaudible] 185 pounder and can really punch that mother
fucker could knock out anybody.
He can knock out a heavyweight.
Patrick [inaudible].
Patrick blasted them with a big shot.
He could put away a heavyweight for sure.
And maybe that's what faders doing.
Maybe him being like this lighter guy,
there might be a benefit in being lighter.
We'll fight that just up two 32 30 and fat.
So if you look at rich Franklin,
okay,
rich Franklin is like above 200 pounds when he cuts down to one 85 and now that
he's campaigning at light heavyweight at two oh five he's walking around,
I would say probably maybe two 20 or something like that.
Not too big but,
but,
but bigger.
And you know,
rich,
rich Franklin,
you know,
he's a fucking big guy,
man.
You know,
he's a big fucking,
I mean,
if you didn't want to be a fat guy,
he could be two 30.
Yeah.
I mean,
rich Franklin was the UFC middleweight champion.
And if you put fat on him,
he could easily be fade or can you tell me why it,
it really seemed to me like I'm the spider.
Uh,
Anderson Silva like his board or something.
He just didn't want to fight.
No,
no,
no.
That's not the case at all.
Chael Sonnen is a fucking monster.
That's about that beetle.
Chael Sonnen is a serious wrestler.
C is a hard nose motherfucker.
And he will take fucking five punches in the face to try to take you down and
look when he's dedicated and when he's on and when he's right.
And he wasn't Nate Marquardt fine and he was in the Anderson Silva fight.
He's a bad
motherfucker.
He can take down anybody.
Man.
He could take you down and get beat the fuck out of you when he's on top of you
and you're going to have to deal with that shit for five rounds because you can
keep doing it.
And by the way,
it's going to push the seven did deal with it.
Yeah.
And then it's hard.
Then he caught him,
you know Anderson Silva.
That's,
that's a master right there,
man.
He waited for his opening.
He was always dangerous.
Two minutes left in the fight.
No one gave him a chance.
Slapped on that triangle pitch.
He's incredible watching it with my father.
My father was like,
this guy's not good.
And I go to and I said,
he's been a champion for 10 years.
I go,
do not count them out.
You're not kind of special.
He might've lost every fucking round up until that moment,
but he saw the moment and he,
fuck.
Is that going to be rematched chuck?
I don't know.
I hope so.
Either that,
well,
I know that I'm chill son and is a,
I mean Chelsea on and wants to fight Anderson Silva gap,
but I also know that v tour,
uh,
is going to fight.
You should know Cami.
That's like the next five to just been announced.
So Vito is going to fight.
You should know Cami.
That means v not going to fight Anderson,
which means I think they're probably setting up an Anderson chill son and
rematch.
I don't know the official word yet though,
but look man,
why not make the money?
This is the money's here.
Everybody wants to see it.
You know,
I know you can say,
hey,
chill son and he lost fair and square.
He needs to go up.
That's all well and good.
But I'd like to see what's this for?
I want to say it again.
Yeah,
there everybody needs to get paid cause because that was it.
That was in some ways a draw and a lot of people's mind right when you,
you just have the fucking highlights from that first one and put them in a UFC.
Add Taka,
Taka,
taka,
Taka Chell sign.
And taking them down.
Don't let the truck over and over and over and over again.
You know the chill shun had dominated for four rounds until getting caught in
his triangle.
He vows to never let it happen again.
You know?
And then you have Anderson.
Would that buy duct bod?
I blocked blocked.
You know,
he stuck it in Portuguese for some reason.
You just have me slide by like this with a thumbs up and another shot with my,
with my average body.
The old spice guy.
Do you ever feel like that old spice commercial?
Like somebody might've saw your act?
Somebody,
I've had a lot of people tell me that you watched that.
I watched that and I'm just like,
somebody saw Brian Collins at this is weird.
Like that stuff that you see in the old spice commercial.
What's really funny?
I mean we're not accusing,
there's from Amy's very possible they came up with her on their own,
but it's very possible they saw your,
your,
your calm.
Never worry about it,
you know,
I just figured as a comic you gotta just keep reinventing.
Keep inventing,
man.
Keep inventing you.
Yeah.
Your,
your persona though is far more intense and sexual than that guy's persona.
What Brian does is a lot of very similar type stuff on stage to what that guy
does,
but much more surreal and fucked up and sexual and like to the point where it
makes you feel comfortable sometimes.
Very,
very funny shit.
I mean it's just,
it's just like you got to see a influence to see live there.
The stuff I'm doing now,
it's been,
I don't know,
it's been very satisfying because I noticed that um,
the audience goes with me if I commit to it.
So I always just go,
this is what I think is funny.
Whatever.
I had a bunch of military too,
so that I'd like this to be really obnoxious cause I walk up like I woke up,
I think I was in San Antonio is a bunch of military guys named Macho tough guys.
And I was like,
I woke up and I go,
I was crying tight American apparel
shirts guys.
First of all,
I want to apologize for my body.
So I about being so shredded.
Uh,
I know,
I know my bag looks like a barrel,
the snakes,
whatever.
Let's move on,
you know,
and uh,
and I was just completing,
I kept apologizing for my pod,
kept apologizing about fast and I'm like,
I'm 170 pounds regular dude.
All right.
And these guys were all just check.
And I just,
I think sometimes I have so much fun being completely either totally absurd or
just do what I just think is funny and just,
you know,
just,
and they get it.
People always seem to get it.
If you commit to it,
it's when you apologize and I think they sent,
you're lying,
but I'm not lying.
Yeah.
Do what you think is funny.
You know,
Brian is a very,
he's got a very unique sense of humor and a thanks.
I mean,
it's not coming funniest.
The funniest things I've ever seen.
Anybody too.
We were in a hotel.
There's a video of it.
I'll get Eddie Bravo to Twitter,
the video,
put it online,
but there's a video.
Do you know what the,
what the video is called on Youtube?
I don't know what it's called,
but I wish I knew.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I will,
uh,
I will find out later.
But it's like if you look up like gay Jujitsu porno or something like that,
young for porn out what it was,
was he started doing this character.
We were just hanging out in this hotel room.
It was a weekend of the UFC like a long time ago.
And uh,
Brian just starts doing this character about a Jujitsu guy who fucks dudes.
When's he holds up?
And it was literally funny to the point where I couldn't breathe.
You fell off the bed.
I just slap read.
It was the literally,
if I had to look back on one of the funniest things I've ever seen,
if I like vote for the funniest things in my entire life as a human than I've
ever seen,
I think you win.
I think that might've been the funniest thing I've ever seen.
Ever tell lots of anything.
We were so high though.
Oh my God.
We were so high.
This was when I was first really getting into pot too.
How long have you been smoking weed?
How many years is it now?
It's been,
what is it,
2010 now?
I think it's about nine years.
10 years.
Is it nine or 10?
You know,
I was getting high when nine 11 happened.
I was already with high.
Yeah,
because I wrote about smoke first.
Uh,
the first 30 years of your life or whatever,
you were completely,
you never did anything.
I thought that all drugs are bad for you.
Yeah.
I thought that all drugs just made you a loser and I was always terrified of
being a loser.
That was the one thing that I was scared of more than anything.
It's like,
you know,
I grew up in like this situation where,
like Boston is like a,
it's a very harsh town,
you know,
and I,
I did not have a fucking clue as to what I wanted to do for a living and
everybody around me seemed to know,
you know,
everybody was like,
going to college,
I didn't want to go to college.
I was like,
what am I going to college for?
I'm going to college.
Just so just so people don't think I'm a loser.
Yeah,
I did what I want to do,
but I wonder,
what do you ever think?
I wonder,
why is it that like La,
you can go to like bars in long island or Brooklyn or or or in Boston and get in
a fight so easily in Philly so easily you can walk in with the wrong hat and get
in a fight.
Whereas it,
whereas in the Pacific northwest,
because west Seattle or whether it's in,
in San Francisco
or even la,
it just not the same thing.
People are awake at shot.
They're just wait,
well,
not with a lot more mellow way more mellow than on the east coast.
Yeah.
Come on.
You spend much time,
you spend much time in east coast.
Yeah.
I mean,
well for Ohio I have,
it's like where we would go for vacations or weekends and that's a little bit
more Midwest [inaudible] notice the east coast people being aggressive.
Yeah.
I mean,
there's definitely more drunks and like fights and like,
especially like New York,
this fucking tires about the east coast though,
there's a no bullshit clause that there's definitely no bullshit clause man,
that you don't get out here.
It's out here.
Bullshit just breeds and runs rampant fucking feeds.
Well,
because you know,
it's what Sam Shepherd,
the great writer wrote about.
He said,
why?
Why do you always look,
keep your,
why do you have all your characters?
A lot of the characters in California and that around California,
the La area.
And he said,
because this is a place people come to to reinvent themselves.
It's a place that where people have no roots or they don't want to talk about
their roots,
you know?
And so it gave them a chance to create these characters that were playing a
character,
you know,
that they were basically lying,
you know?
And uh,
I guess that's part of it.
Maybe.
Maybe you don't have,
like,
I think a lot of times when you're coming from Boston and New York,
you're,
again,
we were talking,
like you were saying,
you're cast in a role.
You play a certain role,
you're given your attitudes,
your given what to believe in your given.
You know,
how to behave as a man.
They're a strong resilient lines to that and don't step out of him.
Okay.
And,
and whereas when you're in La,
there aren't as many people look and you,
you,
you know,
a lot of people come here from somewhere,
so they don't,
they're not sort of held down by that tradition.
Right?
You're not born into a system.
You had neighborhood system especially,
right.
Man and neighborhood system is,
is,
is very powerful,
very powerful,
very hard to get out.
If you don't get out of it.
And unless you physically move out of it.
A lot of times what's really fascinating is when people start fucking other
dudes,
wives touch.
It's fascinating.
You call it fascinating.
I call it a turn off in front of you.
Go,
dude,
I bet you're wishing there's some,
some humans that I know,
some civilians non-actor types,
um,
that are,
you know,
yeah.
Having extramarital dalliances oh,
door neighbors was a lot.
There's a lot of like that swing goes on.
Well,
there's a lot of people doing it on a sneak tip too,
and I'm like,
Hey,
listen,
I don't want to hear about you in the fucking news.
I don't want any murders not to fuck in your friend's wife.
It can you actually in your neighborhood like next door,
you know that guy is into your buddy,
say hi to him.
You guys,
you've had that guy over for a barbecue,
right?
You did,
Yeah.
And you're fucking his wife.
What?
What do I haven't seen that actually I don't really,
maybe I'm naive freaks.
There's a lot of that going on.
There's a lot of people wanting to distract themselves in this crazy world.
They want to fuck.
That's the,
what do they just want to scratch that itch clock and they might as well fucking
playing dungeons and dragons were sticking q-tips in that time to fuck.
I'm too busy asking the big questions.
What's that?
I don't know
distractions.
Yeah,
there's no,
something crazy happened to me yet.
A Fuddruckers the other day.
Tell me about that story.
I said,
I'm in Burbank Fuddruckers and I'm eating,
my girlfriend's across from me and I see her like staring kind of weird off the
side.
Me.
I'm like,
what's she looking at?
Whatever.
And then suddenly she stands up and taps this table that's behind me,
the taps,
this guy on the shore and screams,
this man's trying to steal your purse and points to this other guy that's
sitting on the other side of me.
And uh,
he stands up and he goes,
I did not try to steer it.
No,
you're mistaken.
And next thing I know,
he runs out.
I'm like,
what the fuck just happened?
And what supposedly happened is his guy comes in,
Indian guy,
which is even weirder.
Uh,
he sits down and then he takes his duffle bag and he pulls out a coat and puts
it on this woman's purse that was on the floor.
Yeah.
And then he was starting to scoop it up into his duffle bag bag,
but stupid me runs out of fid Rutgers and chases that guy.
And I'm like halfway down the street going,
why the fuck am I chasing after this guy?
Didn't even have the purse.
Why am I running after him?
There was that incident.
Yeah,
and there was a car get away car.
He jumps in the getaway car and takes off in the car.
Was like a brand new car.
It was like,
I'm brand new,
it's called,
it's called prey drive.
Do you think that you would have done that if your girl wasn't there?
No.
I think if he wasn't Indian,
I would have not have done that.
I think that the fact that his body and I'm like,
oh,
it can't hurt me.
What does that mean?
I don't know.
I don't know man.
I got to beat your ass.
You know what?
Let accents really hard to sound intimidating.
Yeah.
Don't fuck around.
I'll give you that.
That's really,
yeah.
No,
I really didn't.
It's really too bad that that's a hack accent because it really is a fun one.
Yeah.
Who knows?
Indian accents a fun one.
Yeah,
but that's,
that's,
and,
and you know any jihad accent,
those are happy to give you that tight smack a time joking.
Yeah.
Don't fuck around with me.
It's,
it's very offensive though that you find that funny.
That's just how they're communicating.
Yes it is.
And I apologize,
although it'd be funny to see I Hindu cop,
if you had one in,
in,
in Boston,
nobody would stop you phase.
Is that racist to make fun of them behaving like now it's a,
it's a,
it's a mannerism.
Their Voi look,
I have a lot of respect for any culture,
but I mean that,
that that's I think Hindi is you hold your tongue in a certain way and when you,
when you learn English,
you,
that's how some of them speak.
However,
a lot of you know,
India was a British colony,
so a lot of them will speak sort of with an English accent.
Sort of a combination.
I've heard that too.
Yeah,
that's a,
it's,
it is fascinating.
There's a couple of different accents come over there.
It's fascinating to think that the whole world,
like basically like 150 years ago was equal to look the population of India.
That's right.
I think,
uh,
there were whole world was like a billion.
There are more than 1 billion people now in India.
India is becoming a huge powerhouse.
It's such a vast area.
There was an of Anthony Bourdain's
show.
You ever watched that show?
No.
No reservations.
One of my favorite shows really love it.
It's fun.
He's really cool.
He's this guy who is a chef and a,
you know,
he's like,
he apparently was just a wild punk rocker type chef and he,
you know,
did a lot of drugs and wrote books about the,
the crazy world of,
of chef lives at chefs are all getting fucked up after shows or after a,
you know,
uh,
their chefs rather than the kitchen.
Yeah.
And then it just really hilarious stuff.
And He,
um,
he goes all around the world eating and like these really cool places.
Hmm.
And like,
you know,
everywhere,
I'll always love to do that.
Actually.
I love food.
Oh Dude,
you got to watch this show.
I've completely forgot what we were talking about.
What we're talking about,
um,
about Ellis.
No,
no.
Um,
um,
India,
and how fast it's becoming too went out.
Right.
So he went over there and we was in India and was a key,
went on a set of like one of these dudes like doing those India fucking action
movies.
Like how many movies they film over,
Dude,
they think sane amount they made,
they make something like five times as many as Hollywood or something like that.
It's really,
um,
in the has come such a long way in 19,
well I think in 75,
uh,
even even in maybe even the early eighties,
India couldn't feed itself really.
India couldn't feed itself.
Now India is a huge exporter of grain and rice and a lot of other goods.
India customer is going to become,
India is going to become decentralized.
It's,
it's actually,
it's because it's government is so ineffective.
You could make the argument in India is becoming,
um,
a huge economic,
people don't think of that when you talk about it.
No,
no,
no.
That's disrespect.
You can tell India he's fingering this now.
I can't remember.
That one's off.
Flash.
That's yours.
Oh,
look at that one.
That's all yours.
I'm speaking of India and countries and America.
Brian play that fucking crazy Glenn Beck thing.
I am starting to get [inaudible] to me,
this is,
yes,
I emailed to you.
This is what I'm getting concerned about it.
I'm getting concerned about this tag team fucking duo of Glenn Beck and Sarah
Pailin because now they're like combining their retard superpowers and they have
even more dummies that are into what they're saying.
Okay,
dude,
there was a giant Glenn Beck Rally on the anniversary of Martin Luther King's I
have a dream speech.
You got to see this really is,
if you haven't seen this,
you've got to watch this on Youtube,
okay?
Glenn Beck and is pandering at its finest and he's doing it in front of it.
Looks like a million white people and they're saying it's only a hundred
thousand I call bullshit.
I say they're trying to downplay this is they're worried about this mother
fucker taking over the world.
Okay?
Because the retards are showing up in millions for this dude.
At 300,000 students got it locked up.
He's picked up the full retard vibration and knows exactly what they want to
hear.
You gotta he's playing on the street.
Good Monument.
White people are going crazy.
They're white.
People are acting.
They're minorities.
Is this,
is this a Glenn Beck Rally?
Yes.
White people are trying to take back the world.
Watch this.
Look at this.
That is beyond man is happening.
Oh,
my phone cut today begins to turn back to God.
Okay.
That motherfucker should be doing tricks right now and handing out a hat.
He's putting on a fucking show
for too long.
He was a standup comic by the way.
Yes,
he was in a terrible one.
Yeah.
Heads one is a genius though for retarded.
Dramatic pauses.
He looks down,
he cries,
we have awesome.
There's nothing scarier than dumb people.
It sound smart guy.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's a sharp profile.
Sharp talking Donald Dude worried about scars and thinking about the scars and
he's a dangerous motherfucker.
You know people who are downplaying this guy,
concentrate on this guy is starting to learn how much power he has our to Trump
growing and growing and growing and his power base is dumb as he is,
as crazy as he is,
as much sponsors pull off of his shell because he says that Obama's erases,
that guy's getting,
that's why you've gotta be very careful of any play the Pailin one because this
is fucking bananas to buy a Nana's.
There's,
there's a thing that's going on in this country where people are happy to be
dumb.
Plus it's fear based,
not thought based,
right?
It's fear based.
It's not thought paste and they also want a low bar.
The joy,
this low ball,
the same one.
A Dad,
I want him to have a dad.
No,
it's not.
Fast forward for a couple of steps and he brings up Sarah Palin.
Oh,
okay.
I'm sorry.
And She's speaking to you today as a mother of someone in the military,
ladies and gentleman is pretty sad.
Paleo.
This is terrifying.
This is the chapter in the book where Shit gets crazy.
This is where the earth starts to fucking eat itself.
This is like our fall grown right back Marion music.
This is our flower in the background.
Really dumb people are trying to hijack the country.
Oh my gosh.
Nationals.
Oh my God,
and an honor.
What an honor.
We stand today at the symbolic crossroads of our nation's history and all around
us are monuments to those who have sustained us over the years in word or deed.
There in the distance stands the monument to the father of our country and
behind me the towering presence of the great demands,
the pater.
There's a billion white tee shirt
moment of its most perilous,
probably one black guy crying free,
so happy.
There's so many white people around him because he loves white people.
I don't read these grounds where we are so honored to stand up,
shut it off,
shut it off.
I can't tell you I can't take it.
She's not good.
I can't take it.
She's terrifying,
man.
That bitch is frightening the fuck out of me.
What?
No one together because I believe when?
When,
when you look at that,
when I look at Sarah Palin appealing,
I never even see a platform.
I don't see a philosophy.
I see ambition.
That's how I see exactly for power.
That's scary to me,
man.
That scares the shit.
This shit history is littered with,
with,
you know,
Demi gods who ended up doing terrible things and in the name of what our team
and and,
and the truth and the truth with a capital t and we all have this,
this desire to have someone lead us.
We all have this,
this feeling where we need someone who's smarter and wiser,
who represents us,
you know,
and would you really fucking dumb?
The problem is really dumb people,
they get a say in everything too.
And there's,
they're subject to a lot of tricks.
There's subjects to the,
they're subject to nationalism.
They're subject to these kinds of ridiculous Rah Rah Rah America speeches that
don't say Jack Shit.
They say nothing.
It's all just this cheerleading fucking event and they're subject to it.
Then my team versus your team.
Yeah,
they can't help it.
They're dumb.
They don't know they're being bullshitted.
D they grew up around dumb people.
They go to work with don people.
There's no one in their family that's interesting or ask any questions at all.
And they just get sucked right into it,
man.
Right.
And she seems to speak real good.
She seems like a normal person.
There is a scientist,
uh,
heard a talk and I think it was on NPR somewhere and he was saying that human
beings are um,
uh,
what does the word,
human beings are cognitively selective.
Okay.
Naturally.
So what we'll do is when we have,
we already have a point of view of,
based on our childhood,
based on our experiences,
and we have a strong point of view.
And what happens is we're listening to a speech or we're listening to a
philosophy or reading a book.
We'll cherry pick only the facts that support and bolster our argument.
Yeah.
And one of the,
one of the difficult things to do as you get older,
and I think that's very important to do,
is to always sit back,
step back,
and take a look at the flaws in your own argument and the flaws of your own
philosophy and in the paradigm that you carry around with you.
Because that's how you grow.
Take a look,
a critical and honest look at yourself all the time.
And that's my favorite thing about you.
You always been so ridiculously critical and honest with yourself.
Not Critical,
but just always very honest.
Always reassessing.
I've always seen that with you.
That's why you want to make mistakes,
man.
He can make mistakes cause of emotions to make mistakes because of insecurities.
Huge.
It's very powerful to look at other people and go,
you know what?
I fucked up.
I'm sorry I fucked up.
I,
you never look bad when you're,
when you're honest and vulnerable.
I know.
If you're a wild person,
like I know you are and I've been subject to being uh,
you know,
I mean I'm not,
I'm not very good at normal life.
You know,
when you're,
you're living like a,
a wild person,
you know,
basically a comic does whatever the fuck they want,
man.
You live in as a professional comic,
you know,
and everybody else is,
is connected to some sort of a grid and you're,
you're living wild and crazy.
You're,
you're liable to do some crazy shit.
You're liable to find yourself with some weird too.
Situation's a little too little time with nobody watching for a man in a bad
situation.
Yeah,
yeah.
Look,
I've got all this cash.
Nobody's looking and I'm at vague
nuts.
You can make mistakes.
You know,
it's so easy to make mistakes.
Well,
I,
that's that there's the zen poet that read it a really cool,
wrote a really cool poetic book called one continuous mistake.
That's what she calls life.
Life is one continuous,
it's like Jujitsu.
You know,
you start out,
you get tapped all the time and eventually you get a little bit better and not
getting tapped.
Eventually you start tapping people,
but there's,
there's always going to be more.
It never ends.
Never,
never doesn't go away.
It just gets bigger and bigger and crazier and crazier.
It doesn't end.
Do you ever surf by the way?
No,
but I went boogie boarding in Hawaii and it was fucking awesome.
I did not think it would be so viscerally sound.
I was just in France for nine days in the south of France called beer.
It's don't worry about it.
My buddy made a fortune in the banking say this.
It makes me so attracted to know.
The point is,
the point is that,
uh,
I look number one great in a wetsuit,
but I took lessons from the,
uh,
sorry,
I say that loud.
I took lessons from the current French national champion and [inaudible].
He had me on a wave.
Holy Shit.
I served five waves.
I was like,
this is the greatest experience of my life.
But he was,
he was a huge part of catching,
wait,
the huge part of being a great surfer is understanding exactly how to read the
ocean.
It's being able to catch the wave and the right way.
And that takes,
that takes literally,
so it takes rhythm,
it takes patience,
it takes strength.
It's,
it's,
I'm glad I didn't start surfing when I was younger because I would've been,
I would've been out there now with no resume and just,
uh,
and a guy who could serve tubes cause that,
that addictive man,
I can't imagine Dame hired.
Fuck.
Oh my God.
You know,
that's what everybody does.
Really.
What a surprise.
That's what they do.
I mean that surfer culture is like connected.
So have you seen riding giants and riding giants?
I was.
I can't believe you haven't seen riding giant.
What is it?
Can you just take it,
put it up on Youtube?
Well,
it's Laird Hamilton.
They surfed all,
I did see that in a six to nine stories.
High Mexico,
right.
All over the world.
The ocean.
I didn't understand how crazy this was until I went to Hawaii.
Bookie board the waves,
when they start giants,
they move at 35 miles an hour.
So you have to be total Jackie.
You fall way there at Hamilton who was riding and he wrote,
he was riding and they said if he had fallen that way,
if there's a 50% chance he would've just died.
You don't come up because when you fall,
there's another way that six stories high waiting to hit you again.
Send a hundred yards into the ocean.
Oh my God.
You don't even have life vests on life fest.
Oh my turf.
That tube.
Or You die America though.
Let's find out.
They did have life vests.
Do they?
No,
they didn't.
They definitely know you've got to,
whoa my,
I had a life because then you can't dive under the water and be saved.
God riding,
driving,
try it.
Stepped up a life vest.
No fucking waves are 90 feet high and you they do.
Yeah.
Oh no they don't.
No,
they don't do in this video,
you're not allowed to.
You're not allowed to wear like those are the guys on the jet skis.
Not The guy surfing.
Dude.
You know what that is?
That's a pad for when they with,
they hit 50 oak.
They hit the ground.
They don't get the wind knocked out of him and not and then go to sleep.
Go to sleep.
Yeah.
But a lot of dudes get paralyzed surfing a wave that you got to talk into the
white car.
That's Laird Hamilton surfing a wave that he,
that,
that if he had fallen,
he wouldn't have made it.
The video is entitled riding giants.
You'd find it on Youtube and,
and uh,
oh my God.
Yeah,
it's Laird Hamilton.
It actually said,
oh my God.
I said,
Yeah.
And this guy is the first big writer.
There was a hurricane five or something in Hawaii and he went out on the water
and go into the water just to swim.
All this is very abstract.
You don't realize the power of the ocean.
I know a lot of people that have never swam in the ocean before.
You ever get caught in a wave or a in a tide.
We get pulled back.
Oh,
that's scary as fuck.
Oh my God.
The ocean so strong.
And that does scary as fuck when you get caught in a tide.
Fishermen and those guys never lose their respect for the ocean.
Never,
ever.
It's like if you surf in the,
in the,
in like that crab fishing have you fall in that water.
You got about five minutes before hypothermia.
My vibe have like like a,
like a cord in a helicopter,
like rent a helicopter to follow you around with like a safety core just in case
if he could get fucked up,
they can't do that because what the,
because the thing about surfing when you're surfing waves that are six stories
high is you have to have the ability to dive under the water.
If you tried to be like just a helicopter with a thing to hold you there and you
got caught in that wave,
first of all it would,
it would break the cord.
It would break the court order with rip you in half that wave,
those waves and those waves.
If you're unlucky enough,
you'll get sent underwater 20 feet and thrown a football field.
Oh my God.
[inaudible] whole thing thrown a football field,
a football field,
underwater water lying at 30 miles an hour.
You're in a washing machine.
Oh my God.
Oh,
what's that?
A boulder [inaudible] there's your head stupid.
That's it.
That's a wrap sign.
Guys die dead forever.
Oh,
they die all the time.
When they die all the time off of San Francisco would paddle out a half a mile
and they're sharks.
Everything.
He'd have a wetsuit and there was a way that read up there.
That's where the sharks brief for 15 years.
He served that alone in an early morning and early evening.
I would surf a waves that were literally six stories,
eight stories high.
Oh my God.
The first day they've,
everybody they brought surfer magazine brought a bunch of the best surfers out
there.
One guy die waves that hi.
Oh yeah.
There's a break where the waves are tidal waves,
real tidal waves.
Is it only in the winter or is it all year round?
You haven't seen this.
I'm terrified.
I'm terrified of getting riding giants.
There's two that I've always been
terrified of.
Golf and surfing.
Ah Man.
I know.
Cause at my,
when I had my problem with pool where I was playing pool eight to 10 hours a
day,
I mean it was,
it was,
it was a massive obsession buddy.
It was also fun as fuck.
There's something really rewarding about getting good at pool.
And I never got to like professional level,
but I got decent where I could run out if I had an open shot,
you know?
And when I started playing when I was playing like eight,
10 hours a day,
you get like these like crazy rewards for figuring out racks.
There's like this,
it's really like we're a little junkies for some chemical that you get when you
run out.
It's like,
it's a difficult thing to do.
So you get this weird like,
um,
I figured it out reward,
you know,
like Ah,
like you're figuring out life.
Meanwhile you're just stuck in a room knocking balls into a whole like a retard.
Yeah.
But so your brain is flooded with this,
this reward chemical and it,
it gives you the ability to solve problems and use patients and try to come up
with creative solutions.
You know,
even though it seems to be just like balls on a,
on a table with six holes,
what it would,
it really is,
is you gotta you gotta be creative in solving solutions and be rational and like
how you do it and control the ball.
It's a very,
very,
very addictive.
But I know golf is too,
so I've been terrified of golf.
Golf is everybody I know that smart,
they get into it,
they knock the ball,
they're like,
it's like exciting and fun and so rewarding.
I'm like,
no,
no.
Father takes lessons.
He goes to camps.
Yeah,
see nuts and golf apparently is way more popular than pool.
So if that's the case,
then it's gotta be even more rewarding to totally make sense,
right?
No doubt you're outside.
You're outside for,
I saw the setting and it's never,
it's all you're doing is swinging,
just swinging the club and you keep us with cigars are all about to,
you know,
cigars are all about two things.
When you're lounging after you had a big fat steak.
Or like if you're out with just a bunch of dudes and you know,
there's no chicks and just like,
just like
if you want to stink up their restaurant,
they can [inaudible] I'm gonna enjoy this.
I'm gonna knock this ball around.
I'm going to talk some shit.
Let me tell you about this porno that I jacked off to the other day.
I can say everything I want.
I can say,
Hey,
I won for when you,
when you get married,
especially if you're a civilian,
if you get married,
you have kids and you're at home all day,
you know,
or you know,
after you get off work,
you're at work all day.
You have to adhere to one code,
then you get home and you have to adhere to another code.
Cause you're not even allowed to swear on the baby.
You know,
you don't get much chance to cut loose and [inaudible] tell stinky pussy stories
from high school.
I'll fucking just smell my finger.
I remember that smell.
This,
how many guys have told you to sticky pussy stores and you've been captivated
like it was a Goddamn Stephen King book
because we've all,
we've all had these stories.
Eddie Bravo has the best one because he was,
he was having sex with a girl and she had um,
uh,
a yeast infection and her feet smelled at the same time.
Try and he was having sex with her in a truck,
was like fucking her in an SUV and he had to open up the window.
It's tickets head out.
It's hilarious when he,
and he tells it,
it's brilliant.
Like actually Tony and when the podcast,
one of the ones,
you know,
it's funny,
as I've been told him,
opie and Anthony,
I've been,
I've been in situations where it's been,
you know,
like did he use Jim Jim Norton's joke?
It smelled like an open grave.
Is that really the best way to describe it was an open grave.
I've been in this twist weapon,
like this is the worst smell I've ever had.
It's worst get shot.
I keep going.
That's what I'm outside.
Worse Than Shit.
Girls will be like,
oh my God,
I'm like,
whatever.
It looks like shit in the toilets.
Girl doesn't or she doesn't react to the fact that it's happening.
Progress it.
This girl I know that I really stinky pussy and I would know it was going to eat
her pussy out.
I still wanted to do it,
so I just gargle before I did and kept a little gargle and my mouth and just
kind of it on her pussy.
[inaudible]
why is it so typically putting chemicals wet?
[inaudible] just probably smelled like shit with,
with Listerine and then unless burns the shit outta here.
Oh God.
Oh.
I'll probably kill their chances of having no cavities either.
I'm allergic to a spermicide on condoms,
man.
Really?
Yeah.
I've worn a condom since the 80s.
But the point
I saw one,
one,
dude,
I get that and that,
that the Church and gets in my pee hole.
Holy Shit Man.
I'm done for the next like,
you know,
fucking,
maybe that's Kinda Rhea anyway.
Oh No.
But I mean for Real,
man,
I'm,
I'm allergic to.
I'm allergic to that shit.
Yeah,
man.
It's,
um,
there's a lot of God damn chemicals that aren't good for your system.
What we're exposed to so many different chemicals all the time.
Yeah.
What do,
what do you think about fluoride in the water?
Is that all bullshit?
I think it's all bullshit.
But what do you think you think Florida is healthy to be drinking?
I didn't.
It's been around for 40,
50 years and we've had a pretty good control group.
Uh,
judging from what we've seen and Nah,
I don't think it's a,
I don't think it has any effect [inaudible] these things have affected until
they are combined with,
I think what happens with your,
with the human body is we get exposed,
we can suppose by countless chemicals and who knows what they're liking.
Combination,
you know,
hydrogen and oxygen,
you put them together in the right combination of warm water.
Right?
It means the same thing with cigarettes and birth control can be done,
right.
It's really,
you're truly,
people died,
girls die.
If they are smoking cigarettes and I take birth control,
blood cots,
they get blood clots,
they can go into a stroke.
And so,
so for me that's always what it is.
It's a question of,
um,
what are we being exposed to?
What is the,
the umbrella of chemicals,
when and when is that happening and you know,
and all that stuff.
And what are the windows for it?
It's complicated.
It's very calm.
The body.
What I've found is I'm,
I've always been really into health and I've always been really into,
especially keeping my energy where I need it.
And as I got older,
I would always take different things.
Like I tried to supplement and I tried this and more protein.
And what I find actually for me is if I get enough sleep and then I eat just
enough.
Your stomach is the size of a softball,
you know,
the adult stomach,
don't mail stomach size of a softball if I eat.
Um,
you know,
like just controlling my portions and eating good real food.
As long as I get enough sleep,
sometimes that's all I need.
Just personally for me.
You know,
it's just,
it's just a question of,
um,
I can't remember what the hell we're even talking about.
[inaudible]
you're talking about,
that's exactly why I went on a tangent.
That's what happened.
You're talking about if you go to the Applebee's,
just use your palm of your thumb.
If you could fit the food on there,
just eat.
That's it.
Yeah.
Good luck.
That is true.
I mean,
I always feel better when I have small meals throughout the day.
I don't feel like as lethargic,
I'm a glutton and I will sit down and eat immense portions of food.
Jake,
lately,
like dude all day.
Tell me about it.
When I work out,
if I do kettlebells or if I did you get to,
I just come home and eat steak three,
bash them.
No,
it's not me.
It's not bad for you.
There's no evidence.
What's the bad meat is bad for you.
I think meat is bad for you if you don't exercise,
I think meat's bad for you if you don't also eat vegetables and things like
that.
I think you know,
there's another thing that I read in this silly quote that I'm going to give you
the,
I don't know if I could back up.
There was in the same book about all people over a hundred that lived to be over
a hundred.
Almost all of them were red mediators.
Well that's,
that's actually if you,
if you want go to ted.com and the guy who studied the six blue zones in the
world where people live well over 100 years old and one is in Sardinia,
the other is in Okinawa.
And the other is actually the seventh day Adventists who live out in Montana.
And he just took a look at these six different blue zones.
What,
what's the common thread?
All of them ate meat.
Actually most of them eat some kind of a,
no,
most of them all of meat,
meat,
fish,
whether it's fish or,
but meat and all of them.
Um,
uh,
the couple other things that they do,
but,
but the other thing is a lot of them eat fermented things like yogurt and stuff
like that.
And that's very important in their culture.
They also all have something to live for.
They all have a reason.
They get up every morning and a religious reasons or,
I'm sorry,
the other major thing,
I'm sorry.
The major thing that he found was it had nothing to do with religion.
It has to do with how connected those communities where connection they find
when people have strong bonded communities,
uh,
in villages and things like that where they take care of each other and where,
where even if somebody doesn't do as well,
if there's a cultural sort of notion that it doesn't matter,
you take care of that person,
you make them feel safe.
Those are the longest lived people.
Those,
and in the book,
the outliers where he looks at this place called Rosetta,
which was a,
uh,
this,
this village in Italy called Rosetta or Rosa foul founded this in the foothills
of Pennsylvania.
They,
they,
they created this community build churches and they would all move in the marble
quarries and moved there.
And then there was a mobile query close to there.
So this town Rosetta,
so this doctor went there to do this convention and he was talking to another
doctor who had been practicing and Rosetta for a long time.
And this was in 1961 and he said,
you know,
I tell Ya,
um,
these people cook with ward,
there are,
a lot of them are overweight.
Uh,
but they all come from the same part of Italy and they,
none of them die of heart disease.
They die of old age.
They went,
that's weird cause heart disease right now in our is an epidemic in our country,
so let's go study it.
So he took a bunch of people and they were studying it.
They're like,
maybe they come from a really hardy stock,
but the problem with the people that would move out of that town and go to
another town would die of heart disease.
So he's like,
that doesn't,
so it's not a genetic hardy stock,
although people there live long,
he said,
what is it they're eating?
They're not even cooking with olive oil anymore.
The clicking with Lard.
Uh,
and,
and they do exercise,
but they don't exercise as much.
And what they found was that they had a really,
really strong community and that they all had this incredible support system.
So if somebody didn't make as much money or was a little slow or they still felt
loved and when they would go to these medical conventions,
they started trying to talk about health in terms of community.
In other words,
human beings.
Yeah,
you need to control your cholesterol and your fat and there's a science behind
it.
There's also what is obviously very important for human beings for longevity is
connection,
feeling connected,
feeling like they have connection and that they're loved.
It's like Avatar Bro.
Yes it is.
And I'm a Navi.
I think it's just cause they're so happy they get to fuck Asian women.
So that's why.
And you know all these different places,
the hottest women happiness and you like Asian women.
Yes.
Not an Asian.
That's a terrible theory base actually.
I believe it's just lean fish cause don't you always think the health health
definitely has something to do with it.
You know,
diet has something to do with it.
Yeah.
You know,
and Italians,
a lot of parts of Italy,
they eat a lot of seafood,
a lot of fish,
a lot of fresh fish,
vegetables.
But we think of as American Italian food,
like meatballs and sausages and stuff like that.
I mean they have that in Italy,
but that's not really Italian food.
A lot of Italian food is seafood,
right?
There's like you'll Grano that place.
You took us to,
Brian introduced me to this really great restaurant and it's in Santa Monica or
West la in West la in Santa Monica called the [inaudible] great restaurant in.
The dude goes to the fish market every morning at six o'clock in the morning and
gets what's fresh.
It's unbelievable.
Who's a,
he's a bad motherfucker.
He is Sal Marino and he does his,
he's like nine course dinners.
If you've got the Cheddar,
if you get a,
for this shit's on crazy expensive,
expensive food is like an artist.
He's an artist.
He's a maestro.
He goes to the fish market.
He prepares all the meals themselves.
He's fanatical.
The dude's dedicated to it.
Comes over to the table,
introduces himself,
talks to chats.
You explains to what each different thing is,
why they're together.
Because this gives you one certain kind of taste and this like,
you know,
he's got,
he grows I think 36 different kinds of tomatoes in his yard.
He's a maniac I suppose.
What's the name of [inaudible]?
He lives for food and lives for the details.
It's called Il Grano cry.
Oh yeah,
it's on Purdue.
In Santa Monica Bar Badass for West La.
You know,
that's one of the things about watching that Anthony Bourdain's show.
I've always loved good restaurants,
but I never really understood like what was going on behind the scenes until I
watched to Shelly and I was like,
wow,
I want to fuck him.
Like he would bring you backstage
to where all the Mexicans are and he's like,
you know,
he was in New York City and I was like,
this is the backbone of all the best restaurants,
all the best chefs.
He goes,
yeah,
did these Mexican guys came so hard?
Yeah.
And there guys work so hard to restaurants.
I don't know what it is in the culture,
like Mexican culture,
but I really have always been so impressed with how he starts work.
They bust their ass like I am anti immigration dude.
These guys worked their ass off,
man.
They're nice people too,
You know?
Look,
Mexicans in La,
you know you,
you're not going to have any more like assholes in the Mexican community per
capita than you would in the white community or the black communities.
There's always assholes per capita,
you know,
and I know a lot of cool Mexicans,
man,
I love Mexican food.
I love,
I'm not really into the music.
They can keep that music.
You can keep them Mariachi.
I love you.
Your food is awesome.
Your people are cool as fuck you made the best boxers ever.
All my favorite boxers,
Julio,
Cesar Chavez,
my number one favorite boxer of all time,
Mexico.
Know ever see a movie called Amado Sparrows.
You don't want to have that on DVD.
That's one of those,
it's one of my favorite bar and never watched and that's one of my favorite
written and directed by a Mexican guy.
Guillermo.
Something I think fuck up rent.
I think passion of the Christ cured me of anything with subtitles.
I have a,
I know it's a great movie.
I'm sure I saw those.
You'd love it man.
Yeah,
he did.
What other movie did he do?
He did pan's labyrinth.
Yes.
Oh,
that's cool.
Guillermo del Toro then.
Yeah.
Dude.
Pan's labyrinth is a bad ass.
Although I did not like his book,
man.
I read his book.
The strain.
Oh,
so disappointing because it started out so bad ass.
It's a v a vampire book and it starts out where this plane lands and everyone on
the plane is dead.
They've all been jacked by a vampire and the vampire flew in from another
country and killed everyone on the plane that landed the plane and he couldn't
communicate with the plane and they didn't know what the fuck to do.
It's how it starts out bad ass where you're like,
whoa,
where's this going?
But at the end of the book,
it's like,
and then he killed this one and this one came out and he killed them.
It's like almost like they ran it like this.
Just finish this fucking book stupid.
I would love it if I really wish they would go back and pick up where you got in
like 30,
40% in.
Try it again.
Let's try the end again.
Let's try another edit the movie.
It wasn't one movie that scared the shit out of you more than anything else.
The Blair witch project scared the fuck out of me but twice,
two times,
two times.
The first time it scared me is because me and Chris Mcguire went to go see it in
Houston,
Texas.
We were performing at the laugh stop and these dudes who worked across the
street at the,
at the movie theater came over to the show and this was like pre fear factor,
you know,
it was,
I was on news radio.
Very few people really knew who I was,
but I had a good following in Texas for some strange reason and uh,
these guys came over after Sean and go,
hey man,
you want to go watch the Blair witch project?
We work at the movie theater will turn on while I'll go hang out there and we're
like,
fuck it.
Yeah,
let's go see me and Chris require go across the street with these two dudes and
this dude's girlfriend and watch the Blair witch project at two o'clock in the
morning on a Saturday night after the midnight show.
And it was fucking scary.
And cause first of all was scary.
I didn't know what this
movie was about.
I didn't know if it was a hoax.
I didn't know.
I'm like,
I'm this,
I'm sensing bullshit.
I'm sensing acting.
I go,
this is a,
this is not real.
They're not trying to say this is real.
Like I knew almost nothing about it.
I just heard which they,
that woman,
they see it.
It was fucking scary.
It was scary.
I mean it was obviously I was laughing cause problems.
I saw that show when,
when everybody told me it was bullshit.
Oh No.
That was before.
It was the first time.
It scared.
Maybe the second time it scared me is when I took,
um,
I don't remember who I was dating at the time,
but I took this girl to go see it with me and uh,
when I,
when I took her to go see it with me,
uh,
as I was,
oh,
I'm just Jessica.
And as,
as we were watching it,
there was a dude who had his kid there and his kid was making so much fucking
noise and the kid was like six or f five or six when their kids,
and so I shushed him,
I will my,
and this Mexican dude freaked the fuck out on me and he was like,
mother Fucker,
don't shoot my kid,
motherfucker.
No fucking bitch.
Straight up bitch.
I'll kick your ass bitch.
And I'm like,
oh,
what are we going to deal with here?
What the fuck am I going to deal with here?
So you know what I did?
I said nothing.
I just looked at the dude and said nothing.
And I tried to think about what's going to happen here.
Is this guy going to have a gun?
What if I put myself in?
What kind of a situation am I putting myself?
Best case,
worst case scenario,
best case scenario,
you have to beat him up and found this kid,
this guy was suck yelling at me,
you know?
And it was wild.
So he didn't give a fuck that there's hundreds of people in this movie theater.
Like that's the craziest thing about La.
Like you never know when you to run into someone who's completely out of the
fucking mind and with his kid and people with their kids are crazy man.
And this dude I was looking at,
I'm just like,
oh,
fleshy and Chubby.
I'm like,
this is not,
this is not Indian wants to fight.
This dude wants to shoot me.
You know?
That's a scary thing about how many people in La have guns and the type of
person who will just come at you that aggressively out of nowhere.
Right.
You know,
when you look it really,
it's his fault.
Okay.
If that was me and my kid was in someone,
which I'd been like,
sorry,
I'm sorry.
Come on.
Let's go.
We gotta go.
We gotta take you out of here until you calm down.
But this motherfucker,
rational guy,
this mother fucker yelled at me,
man.
It was like,
Whoa,
this is not good.
So that said,
I was scared twice by the way.
That's the second thought.
Scarier.
Like every time I thought about that movie I thought about that.
I saw,
I saw shooting.
Uh,
I always on Vermont,
I was on Vermont,
literally like right near the one on one.
The two actually saw the shooting happen,
saw the shooting.
I was,
I was in traffic.
It was like about four in the afternoon and these dudes get out of a car and go
through any empties,
equip a croc into this other car,
misses the car.
Oh my.
And then he stands there and looks a,
I remember never,
he had his glasses,
his sunglasses on the back of his head and he stands there and looks and he's
just a,
he's looking like that and he just,
and he just casually casually walks back and I go,
Holy Shit.
I'm like,
watch this.
I'm stuck in traffic.
When this happens,
I turn and a cop is right next to me and I go,
did you see that?
And the cop goes,
what?
I go,
that guy just emptied his clip,
that car,
they're emptied his clip into that car.
The dude had come around this way and went off and the guy goes like this,
the cop goes over there.
I go,
yeah.
And he goes,
AH,
right.
And he grabs a thing and then the traffic started to move.
And I'm like,
do you want to go ahead?
And so had he not seen it yet,
and he was right next to me and then the guy emptied the clip,
but you know,
outside,
how did he make it sound like,
oh,
Bobo,
boom,
boom.
But you know,
you figure is it is a construction and I turn,
I see a guy emptying a gun,
waiting the,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
A cop should know what a god damn gun sounds like.
I bet you he was his window or window rolled up.
He says,
you know,
here,
you don't care.
No one,
especially if it's traffic and it's really loud.
Yeah.
And the Dukes to empty the clip right there and they got away,
no problem.
I kept driving and then kind of pull the other way and I was like,
well,
they're completely gone away.
Completely got away.
But you know how much investigation you think has done?
Zero
file a report.
So many people.
I hear like when I was talking about that purse and all the cops came,
they were like,
Whoa,
so you got the license plate number?
And I gave it to him and he goes,
yeah,
tend to come up with anything.
I'm like,
well two of us,
two people sit all the license plate number if you use like,
like typing in a computer and go,
all right,
White Mazda,
you know,
these are all the white Mazda's matched with five of the letters,
or something like that.
[inaudible] do any of them,
Jordy crimes are still solved.
How almost all of them.
It's never CSI work.
It's confessions.
Really.
Yeah.
Still Confessions and human interaction and getting,
and cops were really good at getting people to just feel safe and saying,
look,
you've felt first.
They empathize.
You know,
there's just give them access to see.
I bet everybody would confessed.
Exactly.
I'm serious.
Give prisoners ecstasy.
Yeah,
just hit him over the tab.
Wouldn't stand up in court though.
We need to change the court then.
Yeah,
we need to change that and get him showed him anything that you say under
ecstasy.
If you're on ecstasy,
you're going to tell the truth.
There are drugs that are better than that though.
Are they?
Yeah,
but they don't make you feel good.
You make someone feel good.
They're more likely to tell you everything.
Sodium Pentothal bull make you just relaxed or something.
If it did,
then people would take it at raves point ended up sodium pentothal set up at
raves.
I believe you're right.
ECSTASIES the shit.
But after I saw that shooting,
I remember I was really depressed and for three days I said to my buddy,
I go,
I don't know man.
I feel depressed or something.
Ever since I was told that shooting and my buddy goes,
yeah,
you're supposed to.
That's normal to feel really like scared and depressed.
When you see like to describe someone likes to see for people that have got post
traumatic stress disorder sense.
Yeah.
That's one of the things that they say that it's a beneficial thing by the way.
I think I don't,
I only took it actually wants,
it's just specify,
I've said this before,
I've taken twice scary.
I would never do it again.
I did not like how I felt the next day I had the next day I was so dumb I
couldn't read.
I literally couldn't read call,
this is terrible for your body.
When I'm doing that was not like mushrooms or anything where I got something out
of it,
but my body almost
better and like more energized.
You know,
you gotta go through a mushroom trip,
you feel good at the end of it and they feel a little exhausted.
But you feel good.
Like physically,
you feel like you've lost a lot of stress,
you know,
did they used to prescribe it for,
or if they don't do it now,
still no wait.
But you know what?
People have done therapeutic tests using it,
you know,
and there's a lot of evidence that it helps people with all sorts of things in
their life and their past dealing with things.
What does even better is Iba gain Ibogaine.
Is this a thing?
My friend Ed clay was just telling me how it changed his life.
He began is this,
uh,
this drug that is illegal in America but legal in Mexico.
So a lot of people go down to Mexico to take it and they have these Ibogaine,
uh,
therapy places where they're like some incredibly high percentage,
over 80% successful in curing people of opiate addiction with virtually no
hangover,
like literally rewires your entire brain.
It's supposed to be like one of the most intensely introspective,
uh,
experiences as a human being could go through.
Like my friend Ed said that it was like he re uh,
relearned his whole life,
like literally went back over things that he did when he was a child and to
things that his father said to him when he was young that made fresh day and
yeah,
and but,
but graphically,
you know,
and,
and like high detail,
like you're watching it in a film and you know,
and brilliantly demonstrates all the areas in your life where you're behaving
and acting in a certain way.
And what this addiction really is is some sort of a hole in the way,
you know,
your,
your mind has been wired and it almost like sets everything,
resets everything and lets everything jingle into place and you get a much
better map of what your mind is and how your mind works.
And it's like hugely successful and curing people of Heroin Addiction.
Wow.
It's illegal in this country.
But he said,
he said it completely changed his life.
He started thinking about how,
you know,
his,
his relationships with his family and all his childhood shit and just saved is
saved the way things.
So he just feels so much more loving and friendly and cool and Connie had like
an air of relief about it.
It was really kind of cool.
That's wild.
Yeah.
Illegal in America.
Why would you want to get enlightened?
We don't have room for that.
No.
We got room for big MACs.
You know,
we've got no real for enlightenment.
We gotta look,
they are a million people are going to see Glen Beck and Sarah Pailin at the
fucking Washington monument on the eve of the Martin Luther King.
I have a dream speech.
We have no room for enlightenment.
We don't have any room for you here.
You can do that in Mexico if you like.
If you want to deal with the drug cartels,
you know they behead people.
Yeah,
let's go.
Let's go down.
See that Terry Bunch.
Yeah.
You want to go down there and see God.
Mexicans had been rocking it for a long time.
Man.
Mexicans were rocketed and mushrooms way before we figured.
It's like pay Payoti you and dead.
Joseph Campbell wrote this book about why pay out came into existence and when
the native Americans,
the Peo to Indians were losing all their land and including even,
you know,
they're animals.
They were,
the mythology was all wrapped up in the buffalo and the animals around them.
And when,
you know,
we went through that in the 80s,
I mean at the 18 hundreds when they were essentially they in the railroad and
shooting all the buffalo lacing,
the body was strychnine,
all the other animals will eat it.
And you had 50 500 million animals.
They thought they think probably died in the space of 20 years.
Used to look like the plains of Africa.
And when the PLTs realize that there are there everything that their mythology,
think about this all your home mythology.
Yeah.
Everything you,
you did that you based your culture on is the animals themselves out gone
generation generations.
It was 20 years you,
and not to generalize it was two 20 years.
And when that happens on such a drastic level,
they started taking the parody to go within their consciousness to find,
uh,
that nostalgia for something that should be,
so pod use only started when,
oh,
I started in the 18 hundreds of the pod Indians.
The pit.
Yeah.
That's fascinating.
I did not know that.
And that's just cameras and eating.
Yeah.
Now indigenous people have always taken various,
I'm sure that aliens,
he knew about the,
that particular,
maybe it was just for the Shama Mexicans were,
they had shotguns and they were big with cubensis mushrooms thousands of years
ago.
They've had those for a long time.
Always.
The most fascinating thing to me about Mexico is how they're like a thousand
Mayan temples.
They believe that have not been discovered.
Like they'll go digging up apartment buildings and shit in Mexico City.
They're like,
you know,
replacing something to knock something down and then they have to stop because
they find a Mayan temple that's like,
that's no bullshit.
No crazy.
That is,
they have fucking Mayan temples.
They find them when they're digging up like apartment buildings,
like one of the most complex.
And the bizarre cultures to ever exist.
They used to play football with human heads.
They made these incredible fucking geometric patterns for structures,
yet they didn't even invent shoes.
They had complex calendars that mapped out their solar system and predicted
solar and lunar eclipses.
Wow.
Fucking dude,
man.
And then they just disappeared.
Is that there's a plague or don't know?
They don't know.
You know,
and they know that they used to have some,
a lot of shit written on paper,
but it's very difficult to find.
It's like the weight,
the weight,
um,
Mayan language is written to,
it's very difficult to decipher because like,
oh,
like a word to them or a symbol to them actually means a sound,
you know,
so like,
like,
um,
Terence Mckenna described it.
He said that if you said,
like,
I saw aunt rose,
you would have to have an eyeball,
uh,
saw an aunt and a rose.
Oh Wow.
And so that's how you would say I saw aunt rose.
Wow.
So,
so it was all phonetic.
Yeah.
So all these little,
little different dudes,
a little different characters,
these weird fucking things that they would draw and they would put them all
together.
They all met different sounds.
So then you had to figure out like,
okay,
it means a certain word and how's it?
How's it go with this though?
You could almost say that's the same thing with,
with actually any language.
Yes,
but it's pictures they're drawing.
Okay.
Yeah.
You know,
they're,
they're weirdly,
there's little dots and stuff.
There's certain things that they use to figure out dates,
but a lot of it is like these weird depictions,
you know,
fucking moon with an eyeball and a snake,
these things all
mean different things.
This is very strange man.
They really did this crazy complex society.
Or was that a phone call that living in the jungle,
this weird society that was mapping out the heavens,
you know,
I mean,
think about that back in the hunter side of their wonder though,
if that's,
if that's a product of,
of not so much a culture,
but a,
a set of circumstances.
For example,
like in,
in the why.
Why did,
why did Socrates and Plato and Aristotle and had come out of a grease Wa,
how did these become this,
this,
uh,
source of,
of a bulk of 'em a hub of civilization and [inaudible] stuff came from Egypt.
No,
let's just that.
But what,
but the idea was that Greece was a country that because they could export
timber,
olive oil and wine,
they can actually,
they didn't have to live on a subsistence level.
So they had,
they had three months of the year just sit back and kind of hang out.
Think about that,
think about things.
So,
so,
so what cultures that had the luxury of being able to sell or not only their,
their merchandise or create a system where they could actually be well,
seamless.
Yeah,
they had time to sit back and actually think about things.
So you probably in my end culture had a similar situation where four or five or
six or maybe,
you know,
whatever geniuses were given room to flourish.
I'm sure geniuses are born all the time,
but they're just not in circumstances where they can flourish or have
opportunity.
And this was a culture that allowed for that and they came up with,
you know,
it takes one great mathematician to change everybody's whole world,
right?
Yeah.
Take gene takes one genius artists come on Tesla a hundred and ventures at
fisheries and piggy and gives rise to all the other sciences will piggyback on
that.
So many people don't.
The first g wasn't for Nikola Tesla.
We'd probably be living back like they were in the 70s we probably be a few
decades behind that.
I've heard he was the great genius.
He's the craziest wizard ever,
man.
What a what an in scene inventor that guy was.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I mean there's,
there's,
there's been a bunch of guys who changed cultural like that,
but I wonder if that's what it was were,
whether it was like some supergroup of mines that were like super intelligent
and then eventually they died off culture,
died off for the founding fathers.
I mean the,
the,
the idea that those guys wrote the constitution,
a bunch of men in their thirties that's incredible.
It's an incredible document in the federalist papers,
the great,
one of the great ideas,
that philosophy,
you're talking about men who are in their thirties who solve the political
problem,
they try to solve politics came here from another fucking country that sucked.
I know.
Decided to start another country start over and they saw,
they solve the political problem.
They created the constitution,
they created the greatest government and then you know,
because we know why it was based on freedom and like you were talking about,
it was based on freedom for the individual and it wasn't based on government
bureaucracy.
Government was a a necessary evil for good.
It's possible to get back to that.
Is it possible?
It's not possible if all these people are buying into Sarah Palin and Glen.
Look,
I think it's possible for the idea and it's very resilient and strong and
American culture still and it's part of the American spirit.
The concept and the idea that I as an individual have protection to speak my
mind,
to gain profit from my own ingenuity and my own risk taking to worship or say
what I want as long as it doesn't,
you know,
incite a riot or whatever,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Those kinds of things I think are very strong and,
and,
and I think this country is always swayed from,
from one extreme to the other.
They or somewhere in the middle,
I mean they're,
they're always trends that pushed toward us towards the left trends that pushed
us toward the right.
I think the issue now is that you have so many people who for such a cheap price
can get on TV and if they've got a good speaking voice or a sharp profile or
they say things that are,
are inflammatory,
you've got enough people where shit is changing so quickly today.
We don't,
a lot of people are just afraid at how fast things are changing,
especially technology.
You're going to have people who want to get back to the old way of living the
status quo,
God,
guts and guns,
whatever it might be to go to back to a John Wayne.
Yeah,
so it doesn't surprise me that when,
when when my boy Glenn Beck says we're bringing our country back to God,
people go,
that's the nostalgia.
I remember the 50s of this of,
you know,
whatever it might be,
let's get back to basics.
We human beings have always been that way,
that shit and allowed for a pause after performer.
He was like,
okay God,
when I said God,
that's going to get them.
That's going to get them.
They're going to be clapping then.
Okay,
so I'll take a deep breath.
Dramatic pause,
dramatic pause.
Go.
Exactly.
It's all the musical.
It's unfortunate that that it works,
man.
It's unfortunate.
We named Ed population on mushrooms.
We need to get this population on mushrooms,
drugs or where I draw the line.
I draw the line with drugs as well.
I think that's the line.
I shouldn't take drugs.
So it needs to fluctuate because you had examples and the kids,
man,
listen,
I'm not saying everybody should do drugs.
What I'm saying to some people should do drugs.
What's your thought on this?
What's your thought on not only steroids in sports,
but the idea that technology is gonna allow us to start joking our genes and all
that stuff.
What do we do by Myostatin inhibitors were going to do when that happens,
super body.
I'm going to show up.
I'm like,
I'll tell you who's going to take him these scams like Coan ed,
you're going to look at that coat.
That's right.
You're going to grow your hair long.
[inaudible] armpit.
Hair's fucking tattooed now they're gonna be able to clone hair.
That's what I want and I want them to genetically engineer and I want to just
call me a whole new scalp.
This shit's useless.
Horse tail.
Get me a new one.
This one's a mess.
Upload your brain into somebody else's body.
You think that's going to be able to be possible.
Merge brains.
Maybe some luck.
It starts deleting files.
Crazy bitch.
You let her in your brain.
Well,
very,
let your child that fuck you job had I met matters
flush,
flush.
She does.
They say they're gonna be able to reverse engineer the brain.
The idea of learning how the brain [inaudible] to tap into somebody else's brain
through a net.
You'll have other experiences to experience what it's like to be somebody else
that's not as crazy as it is
to send a picture through the air to someone in Australia.
Right.
I can.
You can do that right now.
Isn't that crazy?
It's beyond,
it's goes over the ocean.
It takes 11 hours in a plane to go where that fucking picture goes in a couple
of seconds.
Yeah.
That's why I cry.
People who aren't scientifically minded who don't believe in the scientific
process and stuff always cracked me up because like you believe in the
scientific process about that stuff all the time.
Talk about somebody who think that science is arrogant because it doesn't
consider some things like astrology or site,
you know,
psychic people with,
there's no,
there's no way to scientifically prove that astrology is the science can only do
something that happens over and over again and you can measure it,
you know?
I mean,
that's what it's all about you.
It doesn't grow from that.
Yeah.
So the to,
not that don't apply to everything,
you know,
but it's both my pee hole.
You can go right over there,
right in this direction and surrounded by a lot of cords around here.
This is very unprofessional.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we apologize.
Brian,
do you have a song that can take us through this moment?
Well,
how come?
No,
we don't have to just go in there and p Bro,
we're going to come up with topics to talk about when you get back.
Just make a p p no,
no song.
We don't need any salt.
All right.
So,
uh,
what would you have done if that guy stopped and ran after you,
the guy that you chased after,
when he,
you saw to,
for people who didn't hear earlier,
Brian saw someone trying to steal someone's purse.
The Guy ran away and Brian chased after the dude.
Well,
the problem is I wasn't fearful of him because if he was an Indian,
I have no idea why.
Like,
I mean,
swear to God,
if you would have Indian dudes all over the country,
they want to beat your ass.
But Russell Peters is gonna throw a beating on you next time we see like Russell
Peters mad at you.
Would you be,
I don't know,
Russell piece.
Peters.
I bet he's got a good job.
I just think,
you know,
even their movies,
like they're like,
they call,
they would movies that Indian people do that the main stars are like ridiculous.
Like India has a bunch of Badass wrestlers.
Yeah.
And he has a lot of Badass wrestlers.
There's a bunch of people that were working on the,
um,
the big giant skyscrapers in Dubai and a,
this was another Anthony Bourdain show and while they're working,
um,
when they have days off,
they wrestle in the park.
They like wrestle for money and they like these bad ass wrestlers like Indian,
but fuck you up son.
That's what I'm trying to say.
It's not in their culture or something.
[inaudible] supplier.
There's Indian martial arts,
especially wrestling.
That goes back way a long time when their culture.
Yeah,
absolutely.
You know that video of that little Indian guide.
It's like a major yet though.
That's pretty cool.
The superstar,
let me see that.
If you haven't seen that,
whose has,
that's why I'm not,
that's one thing.
What does that have a billion hits on it?
How many hits?
15 15 million.
15 minutes.
That's just because it's only this copy of it.
There's a hundred or million versions of it on Youtube.
That's why I'm not scared of Indian guys.
Like all these guys that are in this video right here.
Are you scared of any of these guys?
Well,
Indian people are pretty peaceful.
Consider there's a billion of them take their culture's night,
but they don't get along with those Pakistan.
He's very well,
hold on.
Did you shut off his was getting up and
I guess you didn't.
You've never met any seeks.
Yeah.
He's trying to tell me that know that Indians aren't scary is a beat your ass on
a seeks first of all artist versus video meet years.
That's why I'm not,
have you seen this video before?
No.
You haven't?
No,
but that's gene.
Wow.
I thought everybody's seen this.
Okay.
That little.
They all happy in general.
Really?
I've never seen that guy's 30 by the way.
Yes.
Yeah.
I do this
and they get to know the kid cigarettes too.
They give the kids cigarettes.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Kids smoking is a very fucking strange thing,
man.
Especially that one kid.
Did you see that two year old?
Yeah,
so I was champion.
How have you never seen this video?
I know the Internet was made.
I'm worried about same day as this video.
Oh my God.
Genius.
And now he works as like a choreographer in India.
Yeah,
I watched the show on him.
He was like teaching people how to dance in this one movie or a video or
something like that.
Let's go on this guy or something.
Yeah,
a little superstar.
That's his name.
He's not the same guy as the other guy that played like a detective in India.
The little,
no,
no.
That's another dude that was,
I do think that dude from the Philippines.
Oh,
from Philippines.
It was a crazy scene in my head.
All Indian.
So a little tiny,
a little little person who flies through the air and kicks dudes in the head and
fucked him up
the Internet,
man,
the Internet gets,
exposes you to some shit that you would just,
when we were kids growing up,
kids today,
man,
you'd be a 15 year old boy today.
What kind of Shit are you getting into your brain?
Say I worry.
I think they're though they're growing up,
the most difficult generation to grow up ever young kids today and with some of
the most ridiculous influences.
Like when I was a kid,
there was no Kardashians.
There's no Paris Hilton.
There was no ridiculous people who are famous for doing nothing.
You know,
and,
and so much attention was paid to them.
And I'm not hating,
you know,
if you can get it good,
good for you man.
You know,
why not?
You'll do a reality show about your life and drive around the belt.
That's awesome.
For errors in May where we,
you know,
we talked about it maybe possibly even being therapeutic,
but what I'm saying is we were never exposed to anything that ridiculous as a
role model.
We were never exposed to anything.
You know,
that,
that's strange where all these people are paying attention to it.
I was listening to Nancy grace talk about Paris Hilton.
I had to stop my car and I'm like sitting in my car,
shaking my hand.
Nancy grace is a mad cause.
Paris Hilton was pulled over with cocaine.
She is a repeat offender and she is out on the streets.
Will that be happening?
If it was you [inaudible] and she's to her purse.
Joe,
I heard it wasn't even cocaine.
She thought it was candy,
but she didn't even know what,
she threw it out the window by her own person.
She has to borrow purses.
Homeboy,
her boyfriend was blowing weed out the window like a knucklehead and a
motorcycle cop boyfriend.
Now you are Brian.
You're going to move in and fix her.
Show Ram.
Listen,
Paris,
good person need to connect yourself with the right crowd for in a few years.
People Forget.
She's bone thin by the way.
I don't find her attractive.
Fuck her.
Lindsay,
a lion.
Lindsay Lohan.
Harder to heartbeats.
Garlic herbs,
a heartburn.
She's dirty.
That's my joke about Paris Hilton trying to have sex with a girl at skinny,
like trying to take a nap and a wooden chair.
There's no girls that are built that way,
that aren't dirty girls dirty.
She's built the fuck.
Oh yeah.
I shouldn't say that because she's very young girl and she's got troubles.
I shouldn't ask.
She's 24 now.
She's a young girl.
She has troubles.
Brian growing up,
the creepy things.
We see the photos over when she was really young or video of her when she was
like a Disney kid and it's like,
wow,
this is strange.
Like this kid did grow up in front of the camera.
She plays a twin,
there's two of them to walk,
man.
Good luck.
Good luck with that.
That girl,
man,
that's,
that's a whole pot of problems growing up.
And your imagined growing up in La is this being a reality?
Like,
I mean she was like Ricky Schroder turned out well,
various.
Yeah man,
he turned out awesome.
He's really got his shit together for a guy who grew up a child star.
I mean it's very impressive.
He's a really irregular dude.
He had an interesting way of putting it.
He said he thought that he was a regular dude because he grew up famous.
He doesn't have any point of rep is not like all of a sudden they became famous
like wow,
I don't know how to handle this.
What it was.
Yeah.
It's not say by the way,
maybe man famous means you just get recognized a lot in airports and oh,
you know what I mean?
It means a lot more than that.
And it means people treat you different as a person communicates with you.
Yeah.
But your,
your model of the world is going to be all fucked up.
Right.
Cause you're gonna start thinking that you're special.
You're like a prince.
Yeah.
I mean how many actors have you ever met on the set?
And we've talked about this,
how God damn and furious at these idiots think that what they have to say and
what they have to do is so important.
Because the fact that there's a camera on them and because of the fact that all
these people are telling them how awesome they are because their job revolves
around this person.
So they start to believe it and then they start to act it out and then you come
along and you have to meet this guy for the first time.
You're like,
oh this guy is in like the,
the,
the those swirling fucking death throes of a three year bizarre trip through
ego.
And now I'm meeting him for years and he doesn't even know how crazy.
And he's acting like he's yelling at the fucking staff and,
and yelling at the director and you know,
and doing cocaine before the scene and,
and the goes this career.
I mean come on man.
How many dudes have you seen like go into that death spiral?
I'm married to this show with this guy who was no longer around.
He's such a nice guy,
but he was so high and he was still doing so much blow and he kept calling to
trailer.
We were trying to suit the scene and he,
he was playing a copy editing and he had the guy in the chair and the guy goes,
he ended line was what you better annunciate I can't hear you too clearly.
That's all he had to say.
And he was so high on coke.
He kept going.
What?
You better now can I can't hear you.
See there's a cut.
It's annunciated he goes,
what's that on?
Yeah.
All right.
What you better Nancy.
Ca.
And he did it 16 times in the head and finally like,
why don't we,
uh,
why don't we move on?
It's too high right now.
Oh my God.
Was it man,
that guy would have been something
nice guy.
You know,
when I met you,
you were on mad TV and that's also when I met already.
Did you,
uh,
did you stay in touch with him?
I do.
I haven't seen it.
I haven't talked
already and probably,
you know,
four years now,
but I mean I always would run into him and uh,
and he,
in fact the other day is love seeing that guy.
You know what he said about me on Stern,
like about a year ago,
my father called me up or Tuesday's the best guy I've ever seen with women.
I've never seen anybody better with women than Brian counts or something like
that.
I got,
I know I've got 50 calls.
My Dad was like,
why is this guy saying you're a stud with women?
What is the yeah,
you know,
he's a good dude,
man.
I would run into him like every couple of years somewhere.
Like I ran into him at the Aspen Comedy Festival,
I think,
and I ran into him once in Vegas.
It's just running,
doing crazy.
Great.
Just a soap.
Such a nice human being.
He truly is a nice human being.
Yeah,
it's hilarious.
I just,
he's just tortured.
There's real tortured.
I mean,
it felt like almost like,
you know,
exposing all that and you know,
and talking about it all the time,
it became worse,
you know?
Well what happened?
Do you know how he's doing now or,
I don't know.
I don't know anything.
Just,
you know,
I remember feeling really sad when I heard that,
that he would,
that he could get to that place where we could do something.
I think it's always hard when when somebody suffers from that kind of that level
of despair and it must be really,
really hard on like,
you know,
you're,
you're like,
if you have a child is that way and you can't do anything to help them.
I met,
ran into a dude who was friends with rd.
I don't know if it was,
was the assistant at the time or someone who worked with him and this dude,
like I guess he lived in the same apartment building has already,
and he was talking to me about it to see years and years ago about how,
you know,
he really worried about already and you know,
he didn't know what to do.
And you know,
he wanted other people to talk to him and nobody,
but nobody knew what to say.
And it's like
terrible feeling to have a friend.
I've had many friends who had a serious drug problems and uh,
got real depressed.
My friend Johnny used to have heroin problems,
coke problems,
crack problems.
You'd have everything.
I friend Johnny,
he was a great guy,
but he was a street hustler,
criminal fucking pool pool hustler.
Like if he,
if you told him that story about the,
the dude throwing the jacket over the person be like,
oh that's a strong move,
strong move.
Johnny was like this big fat,
Funny Jackie Gleason type character who was like,
you know,
how'd he die?
Some sort of an aneurysm.
Drug related.
Yeah.
We suspect drugs.
I mean he had like a real problem.
He had a real problem for a long time.
He would go one to the other and
yeah,
there's some drugs like,
like math and blow.
It's like it never,
it never like my friend was like,
nobody's ever said that I had all these problems than I did a bunch of meth and
it got a lot better.
That's never a how it's working.
It's
worked out.
Came out here to stay with me.
When I first got a TV show,
I was on a,
when I was on hardball,
he came out here to stay with me to try to clean up.
He came out here for two weeks and for the first week who was trying to,
you know,
he didn't have any access to heroin.
I don't know if he brought any with them or not,
but it seemed like the first week he didn't have any access to it and he just,
all he would do his sleep.
He just could not get up.
I'm like,
dude,
he came to visit me and you're just fucking sleeping.
And then I sort of realize what's going on.
I'm like,
okay,
you're kicking some shit right now so that,
which Dylan and you know,
and he didn't want to talk about it.
He be like,
Yo,
I'm just not feeling that good.
I don't know what's up.
You know,
he would like lie about it,
you know,
I'd be like,
dude,
you're,
you're fucking like death.
Like do you need to go to a hospital?
No,
no,
no.
I'm going to be good.
I mean,
does she eat some soup or something?
Maybe we got me soup and it,
we'd have a cup of soup in and go to sleep.
He did this for like seven,
eight,
nine days.
They stayed with me for awhile and then finally he got,
I,
I flew him out here.
Um,
because,
you know,
I want to see him.
And the plan was,
you know,
I had known him from back in the pool hall days and he's a really good pool
player and we used to go on these,
uh,
gambling matches where I would take them to pool halls and I match them up in
games.
There was a lot fun,
you know,
and it wasn't for a lot of money.
We do it for like 100 bucks or something like that,
but it was just exciting.
You know,
he had a chance to win a hundred bucks.
I had a chance to watch some great pool action between two dudes were really
nervous trying to win money and you know,
we would set up games,
sometimes we wouldn't money.
It was a lot of fun.
So the plan was,
and I'm like,
dude,
I've been playing out here in California.
There's a lot of guys who like to gamble so we could get some good games.
That'd be a lot of fun.
Let's do this.
And I think as long as you match up with,
all right,
I'm on my way,
Bro.
We're gonna have a good time.
And he got out here just the moment he landed.
He looked like a gray toilet paper roll.
I do a meth.
I don't know what he was doing.
I think it was heroin.
He was gray because I dated a girl,
the same thing.
She show up in New York and she looked like gray and she'd sleep for days.
I know a lot of things.
Drugs though.
I didn't know that it was going on.
I wasn't drugged savvy.
I didn't know from so sad or iron deficiency people.
A lot of prejudice.
[inaudible] my friend Johnny though,
is he,
after nine days,
he finally came out of it like a seven eight,
nine days,
something like that.
It's slowly started coming out of it and I started taking them around and we had
a good time.
It was like one of the last few times before he died.
We took him into it.
There was a place called players,
billiards in the valley and you going to say 24 hour place.
We were out there Campbell until like four o'clock in the morning.
We're eating at Chaya when the day you found out he died.
Yeah,
it was sad.
You know,
he was a fascinating human being.
Man.
I've met a lot of fascinating human beings,
but you know,
every now and then there's a dude who's in the wrong place,
you know,
like,
what are you doing here?
What's,
what's going on here?
What the fuck?
Like this super,
super smart dude,
like really smart.
Like you could throw numbers at them like 396 minus seven divided by four to 60
tools.
She would just bang it out like wow.
Literally that fast and mathematical genius could play chess in his head.
You could talk to him and he could play chess like they do in prison night took
five,
you know,
he could be,
he could do that.
And he barely played chess.
He was just like a mathematical genius.
The reason why I'm so good at pool,
he was like mathematical geometry and shit to him,
just like would like play itself out in his mind.
He would look at a pool table and he could like see the geometry,
could see all the angles.
You didn't have to break it down one to another.
It's like,
Oh yeah,
I'm out.
I'll go ahead,
I'll do that.
Blah blah blah,
blah,
blah about it.
We just see it,
you know?
But the point is,
the only problem was the drugs.
And his problem was,
he was kind of crazy,
which is why he was so mathematically look connected to fast and why.
And he played good music too.
He could play piano,
could play a bunch of different instruments.
I was like,
he's got genius.
Genius.
No,
but a regular social guy.
Fun To hang out with.
Told jokes,
crack jokes.
Wasn't like he had autism or anything.
He was too low.
Very sociable at that.
I'll take a colorful character like that with that kind of flavor over it.
Are you kidding me man?
Like my friend Joey,
your life,
they make your,
he's the best.
He's the best.
Joey,
what a character.
I never,
I,
every time I run into that guy,
whether it's an audition or an club,
it,
I'm never,
I'm never disappointed.
He's always inspiring.
He's inspiring.
He's funny.
His stories,
the way he walked,
the way he talks,
you just can't take your eyes off.
He's a monster.
He's one of the funniest human beings I've ever met in my life.
He just makes me feel like there's a party going on.
You know when Joey said,
what's up cock suckers,
what are we doing?
Let's get this party started and you're like,
Yup,
the party just of started.
The party gets started.
Joey's here.
Great.
It really feels like something's going on now,
girl.
What's that?
Yeah,
he's married man.
it's wife's Terry's awesome.
She was a waitress at the comedy store.
And how's he doing?
Is He,
is he doing the road?
But no,
I'm sorry.
She wasn't a waitress.
She was an accountant because he a drawn out on the road or he does well if he
wants to,
if he wants to go on the road,
people want to see him.
I'm trying to get them to do that.
But you know,
Joey wants to get an acting gig.
He's working real hard at,
uh,
you know,
nailed it means a fucking hilarious actor,
so,
you know,
he was in the longest yard and stuff like that.
He wants to get more,
you know,
what do I think you would like a good TV show.
He'd be fucking incredible on Voice of a cartoon would be amazing.
That'd be good too.
But he would be incredible on a sitcom.
Joey could crush us.
Hit it.
Kidding that character or a drama even,
you know,
as a funny guy on like a fucking,
like a,
you know,
like an informant,
like the shield,
like one of those kind of shows.
He could be genius on that.
Yeah.
You know,
there's a lot of characters like that that you run into in life.
Joey has his shit together a million times more than Johnny did.
I mean,
Johnny was homeless most of the time.
I knew him and you know,
sleeping in pool rooms and you know,
and just gambling and you know,
and trying to try to win money,
right.
You may see people like that,
you know,
you go,
that's it.
It's not going to be a happy ending.
You always kind of know,
well,
you know,
he just,
he,
you know,
he had an imbalance.
There were some imbalance and he self medicated,
you know,
but,
but I got to see like genius because of all his crazy flaws.
It's like we were talking about that robbery Howard guy,
that robbery Howard guy was so fucked up that he had to kill himself when he was
like 30 something years old.
But yet he was so brilliant.
And so he had so much creativity,
wrote all this really fascinating shit.
And like in the 1950s.
Right.
You know,
there's people like that.
Right.
And Kim was talking about how,
um,
he doesn't remember writing Cujo.
He doesn't remember writing the book because he was so drunk and fucked up.
And he said,
you know,
um,
his wife came in and she started putting all these beer cans in a bag and he
looked around and he goes,
um,
Jeez man,
I drank a lot of beer over the,
over the past month.
She goes,
that was yesterday,
dude,
you been drinking in the past two days or whatever it was.
He would just black go fuck out.
He just keep drinking.
And she goes,
you drank this in two days and it was a month's worth of,
you know,
beer.
Literally
she was going fill in garbage bags full of beer cans.
Whoa.
And he said,
you know,
I happen to have been a really,
really imaginative writer who had a substance abuse problem.
So do you think that his like dealing with his substance abuse problem and then
all the,
the torture in,
you know,
of,
of being an alcoholic and doing cold calls,
all this turmoil in his head created all that hard.
He would say no battles in his book on writing said No.
Right.
But what he said was that in fact,
regardless if he had been sober,
he would had the same Maginot of mind.
I believe that is not true.
This is why I believe that's not true.
I think I've learned a lot about writing,
um,
over the past few years of trying to write comedy and you know,
20,
whatever,
20 plus years of writing and doing comedy.
And one of the things that I give credit to substances,
I think substances have a dramatic effect on your creativity.
Yeah.
You can't say,
you can't say that.
You would have come up with that on your own.
Well,
caffeine for sure for me has a good effect.
But stimulant effect.
You know,
Nick Ken,
who is a rock journalist,
wrote a book called the dark stuff about that I read a while ago about rock and
rollers.
And he was,
he followed the Pogues and Lou Reed and the stones and Zeppelin,
everybody.
And he wrote a book which actually said that most of those guys,
and there's been a lot of like there's some strong evidence to suggest that some
drugs,
yes,
other drugs w and hair.
Okay.
But this is,
this was my point,
my point why you can't say that first of all,
because he wrote all that stuff when he was fucked up.
That's why you can't say that he would have written it any way.
You cannot say that.
You cannot say when you wrote something and you were fucked up,
you cannot say you would have written it any way.
That doesn't make any sense.
I wonder if they got there the way you think the alcohol changes,
the way you think caffeine changed the way you think.
Cocaine for short changes the way you think it's gonna increase paranoia.
It's going to make you,
I mean you think about his most thrilling Harfield psychotic shit was off from
the time he was using.
Well,
yeah,
but,
but I mean it was right and they can say that are a lot of these guys got into
drugs cause a lot of their heroes work,
you know,
drug addicts like wait,
the blues are the guys in the,
in the shorts.
And he said in a lot of those guys ended up subset and Stanley crouch said the
same thing.
He goes,
the of these guys were subscribing to their heroes lifestyles and you can
actually see a fairly precipitous drop off on their prenup productivity,
not when it came to weed.
Right.
But when,
when heroin and cocaine I absolutely,
however they become so all consuming that you end up doing that and not your
work.
Yes,
I absolutely agree that there is a detrimental effect,
especially with the ones like opiates and stuff that crushes your body very,
very fast.
You're getting into that more than you get into anything else.
I can definitely agree,
but I also think that we have to acknowledge that they're changing the way
people think.
The paths that you take and your creativity that they changed the,
they changed the direction,
they changed the enthusiasm behind things,
they changed the aggression behind things and those change that changed the
road.
You go down when you're creating things.
And not only that,
you know,
as we learn more about our genomes and how different we are,
genetically drugs
have a very,
a vastly different effect on one person versus two.
Yeah,
that's very important because I've talked to people about pot,
even the kind of pot that I smoked.
I like though the figure out the universe,
you know,
watch documentaries pot that,
that,
you know,
sativas over the Indian indicas rather.
Some people will smoke a sativa and they were describing a completely different
thing and they have a completely different effect on you.
The tech affects your mind more than yes,
yes.
Well it affects your body too.
You know,
it's still all of them make sex,
feel better,
baths,
showers feel better.
All of them do that and it makes you more sensitive.
The rewards for massages and stuff.
Like I never get a massage unless I get high first.
Except today because I knew it was going to be a dude,
Robert.
Man.
I was just going to say,
yeah,
what if it was like,
guys,
we're going to be stowed within,
you don't want to be phoning how to go from stoning when a dude is,
I hurt my back last week.
Can Jujitsu and like a retard.
Yesterday I got adjusted and then I tried to roll last night and like halfway
into the class,
my back just fucking completely gave out where I couldn't stop anybody from
passing my guard.
I couldn't explain it.
I couldn't move.
It was like just constant pain and I was like,
okay,
I'm hurting myself here.
I've got to stop.
Yeah,
so I knew that I had to go and get some deep tissue with the break up the scar
tissue and shit.
It's painful as fighting of a guy though because you have to get a duty to do
it.
First of all,
their sports dudes.
This isn't like you're going to go to a spa.
I go to a sports medicine center and they hurt you,
bro.
It's fucking hurts.
It's like there's this guy today was not as bad as the last guy went to the last
guy I went to.
I literally almost tapped out the doctor doctor's bag,
who's the main chiropractor there?
He told me he,
he actually fainted.
I just got hurt him so bad that he fainted because this mother is just awesome.
He's just breaking down your world with his elbow.
He just,
all your injuries and it's breaking up the scar tissue,
literally tearing it open so that it can like breathe and get PR circulation in
their lasers for that.
I ever say they don't though.
They don't.
You just do.
You have to take the pain.
I went to Brooks massage and I,
I,
it's,
I'm Beverly and I go in there and this Russian dude's then as I please,
please you come here.
And I'm like,
oh good.
And I get on the slab and I come out a new woman,
right?
Because he's hitting me.
Literally I was,
ah,
and he was just
bear of a man got,
and I was like,
Huh.
And I felt like such a girl,
such a girl.
I literally grew bitch tits.
I had asked her to write into my body.
I was like this guy anyway,
so I,
it was great.
So I go,
um,
I looked at him,
I'm looking at him,
I look at his body.
I go,
did you,
where were you?
A sports guy goes,
yes,
I go,
were you uh,
did you do any kind of fighting?
Yes,
I was judo.
Judo.
I go,
did you compete it?
He goes,
yes.
Everywhere.
I have won the gold metal from a Sydney.
I go,
you are a gold medal.
Olympic gold medal.
Judo.
Judo Guy in Sydney.
Yes.
I go,
that must have been a lot.
This guy massage me for 65 bucks.
I got that must have been a lot of training and stuff.
Yes.
Did you lift a lot?
No,
just jeweled though.
He wouldn't give me anything.
I was like,
but dude,
you're gold medals and judo.
It's incredible.
I know.
I'm a grapple.
I though grappling mouth than me.
He was like,
yeah,
I got this.
A deep tissue massage from this guy who was an expert in sports-related therapy
for like muscle injuries and stuff like that.
So he does a lot of range of motion things and a lot of resistance things.
Yeah.
Okay.
So we had gone through this whole,
it's like a half an hour massage of death,
right?
So we've gotten to the end,
and this is what he asked me in the end,
he says,
I want you to get on your,
get on your knees.
Okay.
Getting like a cat position right here with your,
um,
with your forearms.
Like this puts some fascinated in Harris this position and just hold,
hold yourself in that position and I'm going to work your back and this is what
I want you to do.
I want you to go down.
Okay.
And then as you're resisting,
you know,
go up.
Okay.
So he says this right,
and he's going to do this with his elbow.
This is where he's really going to Jack me.
So as he's got me in this position,
he goes really into that MMA,
you know,
it feels like around maybe 35 years ago,
it probably got into it myself,
probably even competed and he's got me,
he's got me on my hands to,
he's here and he's telling me that he does and he's bigger than me.
He's a big old dude.
He's a big old bear on the rest of my cock.
Between an easy fucking feel here and it hurts like a motherfucker and he's
getting me with his elbow.
Maybe I would have competed and he hates you.
He heavy.
I take your back right now.
I have to fucking massage you punk and I'm younger than you or I'm older than
you on your are only for massages.
There was an implicit,
no,
no.
I'm,
I'm not making light of it.
But he's with a very important guy to know.
If you have muscle injuries,
those guys,
they'll fix you up,
man.
Yeah,
because you get a knot when you get an injury and you're going to hair,
you get inflammation,
you get tears and those tears not you up.
And if you get an injury and you don't have it broken down and busted open like
that,
it's not going to heal.
Right.
You're going to lose range of motion.
You're gonna [inaudible] the actual,
you know,
nothing works like this.
You have to get in there physically.
You have to feel it.
You have to know where it is and you have to break that shit actually get on the
actual,
yeah,
they hurt you son.
They hurt you.
They dig in.
There's a guy I went to before this guy was not as painful as the last guy I
went to with Alaska.
I went to fucking would get on to him was a strong yoga guy.
Like this guy does like power yoga and shit.
He's strong as fuck and he would get on top of you with your elbow,
with his elbow rather and just drive it into your spine like right where that
injury is because I've got this knot of scar tissue right next to my spine and
he's breaking.
I can fear like fucking tearing.
I'm like,
it's so,
it's so necessary but so hard to take.
You just want to run out of the room screaming.
You want to feel better.
Oh yeah.
Right after Toby.
Like thank you.
I did prolotherapy on my neck.
You ever done that?
Yeah,
I've done that on my rest.
I've done it on my book and I did in my neck and I worked,
but I've been doing,
this guy has me to tell people what that is,
but prolotherapy is where they take dextrose and I shoot it in your muscle.
And the reason they shoot dextrose with light it came,
but they'll shoot dextrose in and it's a dextrose is basically a sugar water.
But when it,
when it,
when it coats the muscle,
the body rushes healing agents to it because it,
it views it as a foreign agent.
So what we'll do is we'll actually inflame the area and,
and uh,
and create,
um,
and rush healing agents too.
And it makes actually mentally 40% makes it strong and make sure ligament
stronger.
Yeah.
And muscles up to 40% of deals.
I had it done.
I've had problems.
I broke my wrist a long time ago,
kickboxing and like 1989 I never did anything about it.
I just dealt with it.
And every now and then from Jujitsu,
a little start really hurting.
It used to hurt when I played quake.
When I'd move it around too much with a mouse,
I'd get like this painting,
I tore a ligament in there or something.
There's something wrong.
I clicks a lot and shit,
there's something really wrong with it.
But I had them do that in there and then I had them do it in my name.
It makes it,
makes my lower back,
has always been and always tightens up no matter what.
What are you going to work on your flexibility son?
Yeah.
I think that's one of the most important things,
man.
Working on your flexibility.
So important.
I do every day actually.
It's really important.
You got to see my garage,
man.
You haven't seen my garage.
Oh you don't even know son.
All right,
let's,
let's uh,
wrap this show up cause we've been doing this for like six hours now,
right?
Yeah man.
Brian,
how long have you done this?
Two hours and 20 minutes.
Um,
I wish we'd end on a bang.
Bang,
I've got a good story.
Wish I could sing.
I'll have one next week.
I tell you my story that I tell her when I was on a date up in this area where
you want a date with a Brazilian Jujitsu and so at the Poo pooed now who right
now in the woods,
you ever been out in the woods on a trail where the girl you want to get laid,
you want to bang like on a rock and you have to shit.
And now,
oh my God.
And you know what I did?
I'm talking to her and I go,
I have to shit now
I'm shitting now.
I ran away,
I ran away from her up the trail and I fucking head.
And I was like,
I literally ran.
and I got to run it by [inaudible] and are shooting.
And I'm like,
and I'm like,
how the fuck she is coming?
She goes,
so she goes,
what are you doing?
You trying to scare me?
And I go and I go,
yeah,
I yanked my shoulder.
I started kicking it and I go,
here.
I go,
but then I don't want her to look down.
So I go
and she goes,
why are you doing?
I'm like,
Yay.
Like that.
Meanwhile,
we're walking.
I go,
Holy Shit.
Thank God I was.
That was the worst thing.
I can't believe that your ass at all.
I got a parasite.
Am I?
Why am I ass?
I didn't have time to do anything.
I look around and go,
Oh God,
guess what?
I'm I have to shit.
Now again,
I'm shitting now,
but before you pulled your pants up,
he just pulled your pants up.
This happened three t three times.
It happened three times to the same it same day.
I literally go,
I go,
Holy Shit.
Thank God we got over that and then I go like this.
I go,
oh,
hey,
wait.
I'm like,
ah,
talking to you.
What?
I'm shitting again.
The third time I don't get all the way around
and I go,
and you here
just [inaudible] my ass.
My my,
my legs are full of Shit.
I go take dirt in the bag and I wipe it on my ass because I've heard that they
did in the desert.
So I'll try to go.
She stops and she goes,
I hear,
I hear
are you sick?
And I go,
Oh yeah,
we gotta go back down the trail smell like shit.
I smell like shit.
We have to go back down the trail and we have to go through the minefield.
I'm like,
Hey,
look up here.
Is that a kitten?
Ego.
I'm fucking see him.
Ryan,
about birds in the air and I fucking had to.
How bad did you smell?
How bad fucking I had to take up a sync shit says shower fucking bathroom down.
I'm trying to get my ass.
He ever tried to get your ass in a stake?
One of the things you can't do it like bathroom.
Of course it was can get in there paying Topanga Canyon,
their individual ones.
I wouldn't have cared.
I would've got,
that shit was coming off my ass.
I don't care.
So now I sink clean,
I sink,
cleaned my crack,
we're sitting in the car and I have to drive her from Topanga Canyon all the way
up to Gower in,
in Los Filez.
I'm like,
anyway,
that was fun.
Uh,
just call me the poo guy.
No laughter.
Never talked to her again.
Saw her in,
she saw me in a coffee shop a year later and ran the fuck.
She never returned my phone call.
I called her twice.
She was like,
fuck that shit disgusting.
Have explosive diarrhea and get laid.
Just write that one off.
That ain't going to happen.
Here's the reality.
If it was her,
you would still fucker.
Oh,
of course I would
take showers just white.
Well fuck he's the shit is lubrication cause she got a towel.
You gotta fucking clothes pin.
I'm not a pussy.
I'll put a closed those that you kill that shit.
Herpes on fucking,
I'll wear a condom.
Roll the dice.
You got Faisal Ladies and gentlemen.
Fleshlight.
Thank you very much for tuning in again.
Um,
thank you everybody.
We had a fucking awesome time.
And,
uh,
that was the,
I think the craziest round of applause I've ever gotten ever at a comedy club
from the Wilbur Theater.
That was,
uh,
you know,
it was cool to be home,
growing up in Boston and then doing that show.
There was a lot of fun.
The UFC,
there was a lot of fun to bunch of fucking psychos in the audience.
Um,
thank you very much the fleshlight for sponsoring our show.
Thank you very much,
Brian Cowen.
Um,
what is your Twitter?
Just B?
R Y A.
N C a l l e N.
Brian Callan.
That's his Twitter.
Hey,
you guys are up north.
I'm going to be up in San Jose,
September 23rd to the 26th,
um,
up at the rooster teeth feathers.
So come out,
man.
Is that a comedy club?
Yeah.
Where's it at?
Two feathers.
It's in San Jose.
San Jose Rooster t feathers.
And what does the date again?
It's September 23rd and the 26th to the 20 [inaudible] information information.
Is that Brian [inaudible] Dot com?
Yeah.
And then I'll be in Louisville,
Kentucky,
October 7th to the 11th and it's B R Y,
B r y a n.com not to Coolio,
Y and Z,
O e n.com.
And see a cool way to spell it.
Brian's spells the cool way.
Yeah.
With an Omelet.
And I like a man.
Well,
he's not into himself,
man.
He said,
I said,
yes ma'am.
He said,
yes,
he's in the positive as Scottish way of saying we had a fun time.
As always.
Thank you very much for tuning in.
We really appreciate it.
Tomorrow we will have another podcast this time,
2:00 PM and uh,
of course iTunes will be on the next day and there'll be Joey Diaz and Eddie
Bravo.
And we're going to break down UFC one 18 and have a good time.
So thank you very much for coming in.
I really appreciate coming in,
which you're just whatever,
tuning in to it again,
whatever,
you know,
whatever we doing here.
Thanks a lot.
Appreciate it.
Love you guys.